als erstes will die FDP ist Jan dürr
äußert sich in wenigen Augenblicken zur
Haltung der FDP wir können da vielleicht
schon mal einen Blick werfen in das zum
Ort des Geschehens da tut sich noch
nichts also wir haben noch ein wenig
Zeit deswegen werfen wir jetzt noch
einmal einen kurzen Blick auf das was
das Kabinett in Meseberg gestern
beschlossen und verkündet hat
Entlastung nach dem Gießkannenprinzip
ordentlich was für alle selbst für die
die gar nicht so viel brauchen das soll
es nicht mehr geben stattdessen ist dem
Kanzler wichtig ganz sorgfältig ein sehr
präzises ein sehr maßgeschneidertes
Entlastungspaket für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger zu entwickeln Einzelheiten sind
weiterhin nicht bekannt die Grundidee
findet Ökonom Marcel Fratzscher schon
mal richtig entscheidend sei aber wer
genau unterstützt wird es muss Menschen
mit mittleren und
bringen Einkommen helfen denn auch mit
Menschen mit mittleren Einkommen eine
Familie mit viereinhalb tausend
Bruttoeinkommen kann ja auch nicht
wirklich 4 5 600 Euro an Mehrkosten im
Monat wegstecken nach der SPD erklären
jetzt auch Grüne und FDP dass sie
diejenigen gezielt entlasten wollen die
besonders betroffen sind gezielt die
wirklich Bedürftigen unterstützen das
sei aber gar nicht so einfach sagt
Marcel Fratzscher denn es drohen viele
durch das Raster zu fallen die nicht
wenig verdienen es aber trotzdem schwer
haben nötig sei deshalb der große Wurf
was wir vorschlagen ist ein energiegeld
von 100 Euro pro Kopf pro Monat für die
nächsten anderthalb Jahre für alle
beispielsweise in vier Personen Haushalt
mit 6000 Euro im Monat Bruttoeinkommen
und weniger das würde also auch im
großen Teil der Menschen in der Mitte
mit abdecken 35 Milliarden Euro würde
das kosten was die Regierung konkret
plant das soll heißt es in den nächsten
Tagen feststehen
ja und im Studio begrüße ich jetzt
Professor Karl Rudolf Korte
Politikwissenschaftler von der
Universität Duisburg Essen herzlich
willkommen bei Phoenix ja das ist ja
noch ziemlich im Ungefähren auf was ich
die Regierungs Teilnehmer die das
Kabinett da in Meseberg geeinigt hat was
was wissen wir von dem was es schon klar
wir wissen dass es eine Klassenfahrt war
wir wissen dass damit auch versucht für
Teambildung zu betreiben und wir wissen
dass daraus auch durchaus eine neue
Dynamik des gemeinsamen entstehen kann
also die Macht des Miteinanders was die
Ampel auch zusammengebracht hat was wir
nicht wissen die Details der Einigung
und das spricht aber für die Ampel je
weniger wir darüber wissen desto mehr
haben sie auch dicht gehalten und das
ist eigentlich immer ein gutes Zeichen
für Vertrauen der Leute untereinander ja
in den letzten Wochen und Monaten ist
die Koalition eher durch Streitereien
bekannt geworden war das jetzt eine
Wende zum Besseren hat sich die ko
Person jetzt gefunden wir müssen einfach
davon ausgehen dass die Ampel anders
arbeitet als bisherige Koalition drei
Parteien bedeutet systematisch mehr
Vielstimmigkeit und auch das Herangehen
ist eine lernkoalition so ist sie selbst
definiert kollaborativ also gemeinsam
wechselseitig voneinander zu lernen und
sich auszutauschen das haben wir ein
bisschen verlernt in den goku-zeiten das
ist nicht nur um Streit geht sondern um
unterschiedliche Interessen und die auch
öffentlich auszutragen ich darf Sie kurz
unterbrechen weil wie angekündigt sehen
wir jetzt den Vorsitzenden der FDP
Bundestagsfraktion Christian dürr mit
seiner Bewertung dessen was da in
Meseberg beschlossen wurde vielen Dank
Katrin mendorf guten Tag meine Damen und
Herren die Fraktion der Freien
Demokraten ist hier in der Freien
Hansestadt Bremen zusammengekommen um
die Zeit nach der Sommerpause im
parlamentarischen Verfahren
vorzubereiten wir gehen ja in der
kommenden Woche bereits in die
haushaltssitzungswoche des Deutschen
Bundestages bevor ich zu inhaltlichen
Punkten komme die wir auch gestern
besprochen und beschlossen haben möchte
ich vor allerdings etwas zum Tod von
Michael Gorbatschow sagen mit ihm ist
ein großer Staatsmann von uns gegangen
der für Frieden und europäische
Zusammenarbeit sich eingesetzt hat er
hat damals 1989 und das werden wir
Deutsche im nie vergessen seine
schützende Hand über die friedlichen
Proteste in Ostdeutschland gehalten und
hat damit eben auch möglich gemacht dass
Deutschland in Einheit und Freiheit
zusammenwachsen konnte die Art wie
Russland heute isoliert in der Wahl in
der Welt da steht das hätte er sich
garantiert nicht gewünscht und das
Gegenteil dessen was Michael Gorbatschow
bewirken wollte wir werden Ihnen da ein
würdiges Andenken bewahren
ich komme jetzt zu unserer herbstklausur
und zu den wichtigen Punkten die wir
gestern besprochen haben und auch heute
weiter besprechen werden das erste ist
natürlich die aktuelle Energiekrise
haben die wir haben in Deutschland in
Europa insgesamt in Folge des
Angriffskrieges Russland auf die Ukraine
das ist der Auslöser aber wir müssen
gleichzeitig feststellen der Grund warum
wir zurzeit nicht so gut dastehen findet
sich auch in der Energiepolitik
insbesondere Deutschlands in den letzten
20 Jahren da ist einerseits eine sehr
staatswirtschaftlich getragene
Energiewende die wir als Freie
Demokraten ja schon auch in der
Vergangenheit immer wieder kritisiert
haben denn wir wollen Klimaschutz
erreichen was muss am Ende eben auch
vernünftig funktionieren und auf der
anderen Seite die natürlich sehr starke
Abhängigkeit insbesondere Deutschlands
von russischen Energielieferungen und
ich will zunächst etwas sagen zu den
Strompreisen weil das ja auch Thema in
den vergangenen Tagen und Wochen war die
Strompreise die wir zurzeit in
Deutschland erleben den sich die
privaten Haushalte und die Unternehmen
gegenübersehen die sind nicht mehr zu
stemmen das muss man in der Deutlichkeit
sagen und deswegen müssen wir an dieser
Stelle auch als Bundesregierung tätig
werden meine Kollegen Kollegen haben wie
auch ich es aus den anderen beiden
ampelfraktionen höre in der Sommerpause
viele Reisen gemacht viele Unternehmen
besucht mit Menschen zusammengekommen
und genau solche Geschichten gehört
nämlich dass diese Energiepreise am Ende
des Tages nicht realisierbar sind sind
wir weiterhin wirtschaftlich erfolgreich
sein wollen und den sozialen
Zusammenhang in unserem Land
gewährleisten wollen ein Unternehmer hat
mir kürzlich erzählt wie sich der
Strompreis bei ihm vor 20facht hat und
damit wäre sein Unternehmen jedenfalls
nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig und er
könnte seine Produkte in Deutschland
nicht mehr herstellen die
Kabinettsklausur in Meseberg hatte das
ja auch zum Thema und wir werden jetzt
in den kommenden Tagen innerhalb der
Ampelkoalition genau darüber reden für
uns ist klar was jetzt
zu tun ist als erstes brauchen wir eine
Entspannung auf dem Strommarkt das ist
der Grund warum wir als Freie Demokraten
im Deutschen Bundestag für eine
Verlängerung der noch drei am Netz
befindlichen Kernkraftwerke in
Deutschland eintreten das sind sichere
Anlagen die sicher betrieben werden
können und man kann ja niemanden
beibringen wenn wir so hohe Strompreise
haben wie ein knappheitssignal sind wenn
wir so hohe Strompreise haben dass wir
dann weiterhin Kapazität aus dem Netz
nehmen das würde die Preise noch weiter
steigen lassen und hier braucht es eine
marktberuhigung und vor dem Hintergrund
sagen wir eben halt auch innerhalb der
Koalition dass es sinnvoll ist jetzt zu
einer Laufzeitverlängerung zu kommen wir
warten jetzt den Stresstest des
bundeswirtschafts- und energieministers
ab um uns anzuschauen wie die Grundlagen
sind aber in jedem Fall ist klar durch
die hohen Preise ist das Signal
eigentlich zur Zeit logisch nämlich die
Laufzeiten zu verlängern damit eben mehr
Menge in den Markt kommen in diesem
Zusammenhang haben wir ein Papier
beschlossen den gestrigen Tag und zwar
die Frage und haben wir uns gestellt wie
kann das dann aussehen einerseits die
Verlängerung der Laufzeiten ich habe ja
schon vor einiger Zeit davon gesprochen
dass es mutmaßlich nicht nur um diesen
Winter gehen wird sondern um die
kommenden zwei Winter mindestens gehen
wird und damit mehr Strom Menge in den
Markt kommen kann und wir ein deutliches
Signal setzen empfehlen wir auch dass
für diese drei noch im Netz befindlichen
Kernkraftwerke zusätzliche Brennstäbe
eingekauft werden damit das Signal klar
ist wir brauchen mehr Strom Menge am
deutschen Markt um zu einer Entspannung
bei den Preisen zu kommen und das zweite
ist wir brauchen eine Reform am
Strommarkt auch dazu ist ja ein Meseberg
gesprochen worden die Europäische
Kommission hat sich jetzt geäußert wir
leben eine sehr unnatürlich und
unmarktwirtschaftliche Entwicklung zur
Zeit am Strommarkt wir erleben auf der
einen Seite extrem hohe Strompreise die
wie ich es vorhin schon sagte weder von
dem privaten Haushalten noch von den
Unternehmen in Deutschland zu stemmen
sind und auf der anderen Seite
erhebliche extra Renditen bei denjenigen
die zurzeit keine Gaskraftwerke
einsetzen sondern andere erneuerbare
beispielsweise wir können natürlich
jedem dem wirtschaftlichen Erfolg aber
solche extra Renditen Zahlen zurzeit die
Unternehmen die Strom brauchen in
Deutschland und die privaten Haushalte
und an der Stelle werden wir auch
natürlich innerhalb der Koalition in den
kommenden Tagen darüber reden wie man
dem begegnen kann also auf der einen
Seite eine Ausweitung der Menge und auf
der anderen Seite eine schnellere Form
am Strommarkt worüber wir auch
gesprochen haben hier in einem zweiten
Beschluss der Bundestagsfraktion sind
wie wir mit weiteren Entlastung umgehen
und ich bin dankbar dass ja auch ein
Meseberg herausgekommen ist dass die
Bundesregierung gewählt ist ein drittes
Entlastungspaket auf den Weg zu bringen
das unterstützen wir Freie Demokraten
und an der Stelle will ich darauf
hinweisen dass hier der
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
mit seinem
inflationsausgleichsgesetz schon ein
sehr konkreten Vorschlag gemacht hat wie
man insbesondere die hart arbeitende
Mitte in Deutschland entlasten kann wir
dürfen die 48 Millionen
einkommensteuerzahlerinnen und
einkommensteuerzahler an diesem Punkt
nicht vergessen die arbeiten sehr hart
die bekommen keine Transferleistung und
es wäre absolut unfair wenn um eine
Beispielrechnung aufzumachen
43.000 Euro jemand verdient hat bisher
aber die Kaufkraft durch die Inflation
auf 39.000 Euro gesunken ist dass dieser
ArbeitnehmerInnen oder dieser
Arbeitnehmer trotzdem noch für 43.000
Euro Steuern zahlen muss dieser
heimliche Steuererhöhung in Zeiten der
Inflation wäre unfair für die hart
arbeitende Mitte und deswegen empfehlen
wir das den Inflationsausgleich an der
Stelle
und darüber werden wir natürlich auch
innerhalb der ampelkonditionen zwischen
den Regierungsfraktionen sprechen zum
zweiten haben wir auch gesagt dass
diejenigen die beispielsweise von der
energiepauschale noch nicht profitiert
haben Rentnerinnen und Rentner
Studierende das wenn es um Einmalzahlung
geht wie uns insbesondere dann um diese
Gruppe kümmern müssten aus unserer Sicht
und denkbar ist sicherlich auch gerade
vor dem Hintergrund der anstehenden
lohnverhandlung dass man über
steuerfreie Einmalzahlung der
Arbeitgeber nachdenken kann das sind
Punkte die wir sicherlich auch innerhalb
der Koalition in den kommenden Tagen
besprechen werden heute beraten wir
weitere Papiere zum Thema Ukraine Krieg
und zum Thema Einwanderung in
Deutschland hat ja eine übliches
Fachkräfteproblem das wird diese Klausur
am heutigen Tag weiter begleiten so viel
von meiner Seite herzlichen Dank
Ihre Fragen es sind zwei große Blöcke
angesprochen worden um es vielleicht
einfacher zu machen sortieren wir ein
bisschen und fangen mit den Fragen zu
Energiepolitik an
da waren sie dann der erste
ZDF ich hätte gerne die Vorstellung von
der FDP was Sie vorhaben um diese
Preissteigerung auszugleichen Punkt A
Punkt B 9 Euro Ticket sie stellen ja den
Verkehrsminister da gibt es die
Forderungen aus den Ländern das
vorzuführen die Grünen fordern des
Dienstwagen Privileg deswegen
abzuschaffen wie es da die Position der
FDP ja zu der ersten Frage ich habe ja
vorhin deutlich gemacht dass diese ich
habe es auf den Strommarkt bezogen dass
diese Energiepreise so nicht zustimmen
sind weder für die Unternehmen noch für
die privaten Haushalte und deswegen
müssen wir an die Ursache rein also
nicht nur die Symptome bekämpfen sondern
die Ursache sind eben die hohen Preise
und deswegen empfehlen wir ein starkes
Signal in den Markt zu geben nämlich
dass wir keine Kapazitäten rausgeben aus
dem Markt sondern zusätzliche schaffen
auch in dem die laufenden Kernkraftwerke
zusätzliche Brennstäbe jetzt einkaufen
können damit die sicher weiter betrieben
das wäre ein ganz wichtiges Signal aus
unserer
Vorschlag an der das würde für eine
deutliche Entlastung sorgen denn diesen
hohen Preis den kann auch der Staat
nicht ausgleichen und zu der zweiten
Frage das sehr erfolgreiche bundesweite
digital Ticket das war ja die Idee von
Volker Wissing zu sagen wir schaffen in
dieser Situation eine Revolution nämlich
dass man bundesweit ein Ticket buchen
kann und egal ob man in Berlin unterwegs
ist oder in München bucht man kann es
überall benutzen ich freue mich dass das
erstens so schnell eingeführt werden
konnte und zweitens dass die
Bundesländer jetzt Bereitschaft
signalisieren dass auch weiterführen zu
wollen klar war von Anfang an genauso
beim Tankrabatt das ist auf drei Monate
begrenzt weil der Staat natürlich das
nicht unendlich finanzieren kann der
Staat das sind die Steuerzahlern und
Steuerzahler und vor dem Hintergrund ist
die Preisfrage eine zweite aus meiner
Sicht die zentrale Frage ist diese
Innovation fortzusetzen und wenn da die
Bundesländer mit den
Verkehrsverbindungen gemeinsam jetzt
eine Lösung schnell bekommen dann würde
mich das sehr freuen und da hat ja auch
die Bundesregierung in Meseberg signalis
ist ja auch dabei es geht um die
sogenannten Regionalisierungsmittel bei
der Frage wie das in Zukunft finanziert
wird aber ich will die Erwartung dämpfen
dass es unfassbar billig wird denn das
zahlen das zahlt jemand das gibt es
nicht umsonst auch nicht den ÖPNV weil
die Revolution nämlich dass hier digital
ein bundesweites Ticket gebucht werden
kann diesen Erfolg vorzuführen ist auch
unser Wunsch
regiert hier in Bremen ein absoluter
Verfechter der übergewinnsteuer
inwieweit sozusagen unterscheiden sich
im Ziel glaube ich sind sie ja gar
nichts mehr auseinander aber inwieweit
unterscheiden sie sich
verfahrenstechnisch um an die großen
Gewinne der Unternehmen heranzukommen
und die zweite Frage mit Blick auf den
fraktionsausschuss der jetzt zusammen
kommt die zuversichtlich sind sie dass
es da substanzielle Ergebnisse gibt auf
die ja viele warten in Deutschland ja
ich kenne ja die Äußerung von
entwurfenschulte ich habe das auch schon
öffentlich mit ihm ausgetragen das war
sehr bogenschulte vorschlägt ist ja eine
allgemeine übergewinnsteuer oder eine
allgemeine über Umsatzsteuer
italienisches Modell und das wäre ein
Endung des deutschen Steuerrechts im
Sinne von wer erfolgreich ist der wird
einfach pauschal weggesteuert das wäre
schädlich für den Standort Deutschland
und das kann ich das Ziel sein hier
haben wir etwas anderes vorliegen
nämlich ein Marktversagen im Strommarkt
derzeit ganz konkret ist ja absolut
unplausibel was da gerade passiert und
da fallen extra Renditen auf bestimmte
Produk an und jetzt geht es darum wie
man mit welchem Instrument man innerhalb
des Strommarktes dafür sorgt dass die
Preise wieder angemessen sind das ist
etwas völlig anderes das muss man noch
mal betonen darf man auch nicht in einen
Topf werfen also insofern die
übergewinnsteuer von den bogenschulte
würde Unternehmen wie biontech aus dem
Land gerade zu treiben und deswegen ist
das das falsche Konzept aber ich habe
Meseberg auch so verstanden und die
Besprechung dort dass man etwas
innerhalb des Strommarktes machen will
und das muss das Ziel sein damit der
Preis wieder runter geht neben der
Ausweitung der Menge über die sprach
die zweite Frage zum Koalitionsausschuss
wie weit rechnen Sie damit
substanziellen Ergebnissen ja ich gehe
davon aus dass wir insbesondere über das
dritte Entlastungspaket sprechen werden
und da gibt es ja Vorstellungen die
teilweise deckungsgleich sind teilweise
nicht das ist in der Koalition absolut
normal aber wir haben ja schon einmal
bewiesen mit dem ersten und zweiten
Entlastungspaket dass wir da in der Lage
sind auch wirklich Großes zu bewirken
das tut ja seine gleichen Europa dieses
erst und zweite Paket und jetzt reden
wir über ein drittes und da habe ich vor
die Schwerpunkte genannt aber ich bin da
sehr zuversichtlich dass wir das
kurzfristig hinbekommen
gibt es weitere Fragen
mit cooler dpa sie sagt wir wollen es
kurzfristig hinbekommen was bedeutet das
vom Ablauf des was ist ihr Zieldatum
dafür also ich kann Ihnen jetzt keine
Uhrzeiten sagen aber kurzfristig heißt
wir werden in den kommenden Tagen
darüber sprechen innerhalb der Koalition
man muss nun wissen dass manche
Maßnahmen des ersten und zweiten
Entlastungspaket ist ja noch gar nicht
zur Auszahlung gekommen sind deswegen
sind wir sozusagen glücklicherweise in
der politischen
Reihenfolge vor der Welle derzeit und
werden jetzt in den kommenden Tagen und
zusammensetzen sehen Sie uns nach dass
wir das vertrauensvoll wie bei den
Koalitionsverhandlungen hinter
verschlossener Tür machen und damit
einem gemeinsamen Dritten
Entlastungspaket öffentlich gehen und
ich will wie gesagt keine Stunde nennen
das ist unredlich aber das wird in den
kommenden Tagen der Fall sein
wie ist denn die Stimmungslage innerhalb
der Fraktion was das
Infektionsschutzgesetz angeht das wurde
jetzt ziemlich kontrovers diskutiert
zwischen Herrn Lauterbach und Herrn
Buschmann können Sie uns da noch mal in
ein Einblick in die Gefühlswelt der
Fraktion geben ja also gerade was das
Thema Infektionsschutzgesetz da ist ja
in den letzten Jahren auch über den
letzten Tagen Entschuldigung über
epidemische Lage und ähnliches geredet
worden die hat ja die FDP beendet und im
Deutschen Bundestag ist unsere Haltung
ja sehr klar es wird keine
weitergehenden Maßnahmen geben wie
Lockdown Schulschließung Ausgangssperren
all das was die große Koalition hatte
haben wir richtigerweise nicht mehr im
Infektionsschutzgesetz und auf der
anderen Seite empfehle ich den Ländern
was beispielsweise die Möglichkeit einer
maskenpflicht in Innenräumen betrifft
sie nicht anzuwenden wenn die Lage ist
nicht erfordert viele andere europäische
Länder haben weitergehende Maßnahmen die
Sie derzeit nicht anwenden wir haben
wenige Maßnahmen in Deutschland eine ist
die Möglichkeit werden wir haben eines
die Möglichkeit der maskenpflicht in
Innenräumen aber ich empfehle wirklich
den Ländern an dass nicht einfach so zu
ziehen nach dem Motto jetzt geht's
sondern das muss Lage angemessen sein
und so wird es ja dann auch im Gesetz
stehen da sprechen wir in diesen Tagen
drüber an die Verhandlung ja zwischen
den parlamentarischen Gruppen also
zwischen den Regierungsfraktionen laufen
derzeit und klar ist auch da kann es
immer wieder Änderungen geben aber da
reden wir jetzt innerhalb der
Ampelkoalition drüber
nicht dann danke ich ganz herzlich für
ihr Kommen und noch einen schönen Tag
vielen Dank
soweit also die Pressekonferenz der
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion im Rahmen ihrer
Klausurtagung in Bremen und nach wie vor
bei uns im Studio ist Professor Karl
Rudolf Korte Politikwissenschaftler von
der Universität Duisburg-Essen ja im
Mittelpunkt dieser Pressekonferenz von
Christian Dörr stand das
Entlastungspaket dass da in Umrissen die
Koalition in Meseberg beschlossen hat
wissen wir jetzt ein bisschen klarer was
auf uns zukommt einmal haben wir ein
Gefühl bekommen dass die Parteien das
jetzt nachverhandelt einmal die Fraktion
und dann auch die Parteien und am
Wochenende scheint ja auch eine ein
Treffen des Koalitionsausschusses zu
sein zu kommen insofern haben wir einen
fahrplanvorstellung bekommen dass es
sich parlamentarisiert vermutlich gegen
Ende September inhaltlich finde ich kann
man schon erkennen er hat ja ganz
bewusst mit der Strom Regulierung mit
der strompreisreform angefangen dass das
vielleicht das brückenthema sein könnte
dort nicht übergewinne so wird es nicht
bezeichnet aber doch zusätzliches
Wachstum abzugreifen bei Firmen die das
im Moment unverdienter weisen bekommen
und das wäre vielleicht die Brücke
zwischen dem was die anderen Partner
vorschlagen und der FDP also das eine
übergewinnsteuer die Christian dürr so
nicht nennen wollte aber faktisch ist es
wahrscheinlich dasselbe das in einem
Teil Markt erhöhte Gewinne durch den
Ukraine Krieg und die Situation jetzt
abgeschöpft werden soll das wäre eine
Kröte die die FDP schlucken muss jetzt
hat Christian dürr natürlich was ganz
anderes an den Anfang seiner
Pressekonferenz gesetzt nämlich die
Laufzeitverlängerung der Kernkraftwerke
und zwar nicht nur um ein paar Monate
wie das vielleicht die Grünen mittragen
würden sondern gleich um zwei Jahre ist
das tragbar für die beiden anderen
Parteien ja wir erleben ja Politik
Paradoxon das heißt also Parteien die
etwas vereinbart haben machen am Ende
komplett anderes das hat es häufig in
historischen Konstellationen gegeben so
auch diesmal also die SPD ist ja
gleichermaßen davon betroffen werden wir
ja gleich auf der Pressekonferenz
erleben dass sie auf darauf hinweisen 12
Uhr in Dresden erwarten wir die
Pressekonferenz der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion da wird sich dann
zum Auftakt dieser Klausurtagung der SPD
der Fraktionsvorsitzende Mütze nicht
melden ist immer live dabei und ich
hatte sie unterbrochen aber dass die SPD
aufrüstet dass sie Kriegswaffen nicht
nur anschafft sondern auch in
Kriegsgebiete liefert das ist ja völlig
ungewöhnlich für die SPD und die Grünen
müssen praktisch das fossile weiter auf
das fossilen beharren was sie immer
bekämpft haben dass man über das Fossil
überhaupt erreichen kann dass wir über
diesen Winter kommen und gleichermaßen
wo ist die Kröte im Sinne des Politik
Paradoxons für die FDP bisher hat sie da
nicht sehr viel an Bewegung gezeigt die
anderen waren eigentlich beweglicher um
Seitenwände zu interpretieren der Rabatt
vielleicht ein wenig ungewöhnlich für
die FDP nichts marktliches sondern
regulierendes und hier deutet sich auch
an dass sie doch eine Art von
Abschöpfung mitträgt damit also ich
fasse das mal zusammen wir könnten uns
ein Kompromiss auf dem Strommarkt
vorstellen einerseits müssen die Grünen
akzeptieren dass die Laufzeit der
Kernkraftwerke verlängert wird die
Kohlekraftwerke haben sie ja schon
geschluckt auf der anderen Seite muss
die FDP akzeptieren dass in irgendeiner
Form auch wenn man das vielleicht anders
nennt zusätzliche Gewinne auf dem
Strommarkt abgeschöpft werden nächstes
Thema Steuerrecht über das Christian
dürr gesprochen hat da hat die FDP
wieder Ihr Wunschthema
ins Gespräch gebracht nämlich ein Abbau
der kalten Progression ist das für die
anderen parteientragbar der Katze hat es
unterstützt weil er es als
Finanzminister auch schon gemacht hat es
ist nicht ungewöhnlich insofern wird die
Sozialdemokratie sich dem nicht
widersetzen ob dann die Grünen das
mittragen hängt eben von den anderen
Bereichen ab aber der Grundgedanke dass
wir jetzt nur im Sinne einer
entlasteritis Teile zusammentragen als
kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner ist nicht
der Grundgedanke mit dem man die Ampel
ein bisher konfrontieren sollte sondern
aus der Dynamik des gemeinsamen und der
Macht des Miteinanders sollte sich etwas
originell Neues entwickeln der Rest ist
klein klein wie wir Koalition immer
kennen kleinste gemeinsame Nenner ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass die neue
Herausforderung vor dir wir in diesem
Winter stehen mit diesem kleinsten
gemeinsamen Nenner lösbar ist und
deswegen braucht man sowas wie Meseberg
vielleicht auch die Klausur die die das
Treffen am Wochenende der Parteispitzen
um sich einen Ruck zu geben wo das neue
gemeinsame liegen könnte auch originell
im Abgleich mit anderen Ländern die auch
vor gleichen
von der gleichen Herausforderung stehen
die FDP musste sich ja auch noch in
einigen anderen Punkten bewegen oder hat
sich bewegt bei einer neuen euro-ticket
vielleicht auch beim ein oder anderen
Punkt den wir noch besprechen können ich
möchte jetzt gerne den Blick mal in
Richtung SPD wenden denn die
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion hatte bereits vor
der Kabinettsklausur ein sehr
detailliertes Konzept vorgelegt wie das
Paket zur Entlastung der Bürger aussehen
soll und zu den Ergebnissen von Meseberg
äußerte sich heute morgen der
SPD-Fraktionschef Mützenich im ARD
Morgenmagazin
ich glaube es handelt sich nur noch um
wenige Tage dass wir Entscheidungen
treffen das ist gut dass wir in diesen
Tagen sowohl die Regierung aber auch die
Fraktionen und wir als SPD-Fraktion hier
in Dresden zusammenkommen um letzte
Einzelheiten zu besprechen wir hatten ja
Anfang der Woche bereits Vorschläge
gemacht wir sind vorangegangen und viele
haben sich dem angeschlossen dass das
dritte Entlastungspaket nach zwei
entlastungspaketen auch mit großen
Summen die sich ja auch noch nicht
bisher überall gezeigt haben entlastet
werden sollen und darauf kommt es jetzt
an wir wollen das zielgenau machen dazu
bedarf es noch der einen oder anderen
Frage und wir müssen ja auch Gesetze
dazu umsetzen und der Bundestag kommt in
der nächsten Woche zu dem Beratungen
über den Haushalt für 2023 zusammen ich
finde das ist ein guter Zeitpunkt wir
haben insbesondere Rentnerinnen und
Rentner Auszubildende Studierende im
Blick aber insbesondere natürlich auch
diejenigen und da hat ja Fratscher in
der vormoderation von gesprochen
diejenigen mit kleinem und mittlerem
Einkommen Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer Familien das sind
diejenigen die unter den
Herausforderungen unter den steigenden
Preisen und das betrifft ja nicht nur
alleine den Energiesektor sondern auch
Ernährung und viele andere Bereiche auch
letztlich ein größeres Problem auf sich
zukommen sehen oder bereits haben und
genau das sollen die Gruppen sein es ist
in der Tat schwierig dass man eben
zielgenau die Gruppen auch letztlich
erreicht aber ich glaube es gibt
genügend mittlerweile Instrumente dafür
und wir wollen sie auch fortentwickeln
in den nächsten Monaten und Jahren wir
müssen das innerhalb einer Koalition
zusammenführen und ich bin immer dankbar
für Ratschläge am Ende entscheidet aber
eben der Deutsche Bundestag und damit
wir auch als die stärkste
Regierungsfraktion und deswegen sind die
Gespräch aber auch unsere Vorstellung
von Anfang der Woche so wichtig gewesen
wir wollen bereits in diesem Jahr eben
auch zu diesem dritten Entlastungspaket
kommen zumindest ist das unsere
Vorstellung und ich glaube es gibt
genügend Mittel noch im Haushalt
vorhanden und wir dürfen nicht nur auf
dem Bund schauen sondern die Länder auch
und wir wollen ja auch dass es eine
gerechte gemeinsame Beteiligung
staatlicher Institutionen gibt und
deswegen glaube ich
entwickelt sich schon eine Summe die
möglich ist eben gezielte Entlastung auf
den Weg zu bringen da wo der Staat
versagt müssen auch staatliche
Entscheidungen getroffen werden und das
betrifft auch die übergewinnsteuer weil
es nicht unternehmerische Initiative ist
sondern auf der anderen Seite
Mitnahmeeffekte und die brauchen die
Menschen und deswegen haben wir die
übergewinnsteuer in die Diskussion
eingebracht ich mache mir keine
Illusionen innerhalb der FDP gibt es
hier nicht eine große Sympathie dafür
aber ich finde für die politische
Debatte ist das notwendig und am Ende
entscheiden auch die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger mit darüber weil die politische
Stimmungslage ist natürlich auch für
jede Partei wichtig
ja das war der
SPD-Fraktionsvorsitzende heute morgen im
ARD Morgenmagazin und wir warten auf
denselben Rolf Mützenich jetzt live aus
Dresden zum Auftakt der
fraktionsssitzung der SPD in Dresden
12.30 ist diese Pressekonferenz
angekündigt im Moment tut sich da noch
nichts und es gibt uns die Gelegenheit
dass jetzt ein bisschen
einzuordnen zunächst mal den ersten
beiden
entlastungspaketen hat man ja
vorgeworfen sie seien die zielgenau
gewesen das sei mit der Gießkanne Geld
ausgeschüttet worden und die dies
wirklich brauchen die hätten zu wenig
bekommen wie kann man das denn überhaupt
und deutet sich das an in einem dritten
Paket verhindern oder besser machen
einmal Zeit gewinnen also besser
überlegen im Sinne der Problemlösung
damit auch keinen vergessen aber die
Krisenkommunikation auch grundsätzlich
verändert die Verschonung von uns als
Bürgern vor dem ö biologischen oder vor
dem was uns bevorsteht ist die
grundsätzlich falsche Annahme der
Grundsatz dass wir wie mit Pflastern
praktisch alles kurieren können mit
zusätzlichem Geld und jedem helfen wird
ja nicht einlösbar sein Inflation und
das Geld kostet mehr als es vor einigen
Jahren der Fall war lassen es gar nicht
mehr zu als der krisenmodus der Politik
ist ein anderer wir brauchen eine andere
Krisenkommunikation die uns als Bürger
auch einbezieht und insofern wird das
Auflisten von einzelnen
entlastungsschritten am Ende nicht dazu
führen dass wir mit dem dritten Paket
zufriedener sind jetzt muss es die SPD
ja besonders Schmerzen das ausgerechnet
der Vorsitzende der
cdu/csu-fraktion März gesagt hat besser
1000 für die Bedürftigen als 300 für
alle aber an der Stelle muss ich Sie um
Ihre Antwort bringen denn ich sehe auf
meinem vorschau-monitor das Rolf
Mützenich vor die Kamera getreten ist
ich freue mich dass ich viele auch hier
wieder sehen darf nach einer Sommerpause
die sie hoffentlich gesundheitlich gut
erleben durften und sich ein bisschen
erholen durften die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sind natürlich aus den
Wahlkreisen hier nach Dresden angereist
weil nicht nur die Klausur für uns ein
wichtiger Auftakt für die kommende Woche
der haushaltswoche ist sondern wir haben
uns insbesondere zwei Schwerpunkte
herausgesucht schon vor einigen Monaten
weil wir wollten nicht nur ganz aktuelle
Themen behandeln sondern eben auch
langfristige Themen und deswegen werden
gleich 206 Abgeordnete ganz verschiedene
Betriebe Unternehmen hier in der Region
in Dresden besuchen die sich nämlich auf
die Herausforderungen einer neuen
Arbeits- und Wirtschaftswelt einstellen
wir hatten unheimlich viele Anfragen
gehabt wo man mit der SPD-Fraktion eben
diese Herausforderung
entweder zeigen oder auch diskutieren
will und dann natürlich zum zweiten
insbesondere morgen in dieser Klausur wo
wir mit dem Bundeskanzler mit den beiden
Parteivorsitzenden auch das vorbereiten
wollen was wir unter der Überschrift
Entlastungspaket vergangenen Sonntag die
Debatte angestoßen haben ganz bewusst
haben wir uns in der Sommerpause nicht
jeden Tag mit wieder neuen Vorschlägen
gemeldet oder irgendwas kommentiert
sondern wir haben in der Sommerpause
sehr intensiv mit den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ein umfangreiches Papier
beraten wo wir unsere Vorstellungen zur
Entlastung der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
auf den Weg gebracht haben und ich
glaube schon dass wir ein wichtiges
Thema als Sozialdemokraten
Sozialdemokraten gesetzt haben nämlich
dass der direkten Entlastung auf der
einen Seite dass wir bestimmte Gruppen
in den Fokus nehmen wollen wir rent und
Rentner wie Studierende und
Auszubildende aber eben insbesondere die
die nur über kleine und mittlere
Einkommen verfügen und denen es so
wichtig ist dass sie auch unterstützt
werden unterstützt nicht nur durch eine
gute Tarifpolitik sondern eben auch
durch staatliche Unterstützung da haben
wir Vorschläge gemacht sie natürlich
zusammengeführt werden müssen und damit
es auch nicht so Irritationen kommt dass
die heutige Meldung die ich glaube ein
Kollege von ihnen verbreitet hat bereits
heute der Koalitionsausschuss
stattfindet das kann ich nicht
bestätigen aber dass der
Koalitionsausschuss natürlich das
Gremium ist was am Ende die
verschiedenen Vorstellungen aus den
Parteien zusammenführt das wird Sie
nicht überraschen und ich bin sehr
sicher dass wir in den nächsten Stunden
und Tagen Entscheidungen treffen auch
vor dem Hintergrund
dass jetzt bestimmte
Unterstützungsleistungen aus den beiden
Paketen auslaufen und ich glaube das ist
ein ganz wichtiges Signal was Anfang
September gegeben werden muss
Tagen
ist es denn ausgemachte Sache dass man
nicht zum Beginn der Haushaltsberatungen
um im Bundestag sprich Dienstag früh um
10 Uhr glaube ich Entscheidungen
getroffen haben will und die zweite
Frage zur Autorität gefasst vor ein paar
Tagen einen Aufruf für jemanden sich
auch Abgeordnete in ihrer Fraktion
beteiligt haben da werden Verhandlungen
mit Russland gefordert eine
Vermittlerrolle Chinas und auch die
Lieferung schwerer Waffen wird abgelehnt
halten wie diese Vorschläge für abwegig
oder eher pflegestufungen also vielen
Dank Fischer ich bin der festen
Auffassung und das habe ich auch den
anderen Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus den
Koalitionsparteien gesagt dass wir vor
der Haushalt gute Klarheit haben wollen
ich glaube es bringt überhaupt nichts
dass man in dieser haushaltswoche wo wir
ja in dem Mittwoch auch eben den
Bundeskanzler hören werden dass wir dann
erst danach über bestimmte
Entscheidungen treffen ich glaube das
ist jetzt notwendig jetzt ein klares
Signal auch für die Beratungen für das
Jahr 2023 für den Etat zu geben ob ich
überzeugt habe das kann ich jetzt in
dieser Minute nicht sagen aber ich
glaube jeder der darüber nachdenkt was
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger an Signal
brauchen ist dass es jetzt in der
nächsten in den nächsten Stunden in den
nächsten Tagen auch passieren muss ich
glaube das Papier was Sie angesprochen
haben wo auch Mitglieder unserer
Fraktion sich wiederfinden wollten
besteht insbesondere darin und das muss
ich sagen habe ich sehr vermisst darin
dass man zum Beispiel den
Generalsekretär der Vereinten Nationen
Herrn guterisch der Zusammenbau auch mit
dem türkischen Präsidenten da mag man
drüber denken was man will ob der
türkische Präsident hier der richtige
Gesprächspartner für solche
Herausforderungen nämlich den Krieg am
Verhandlungstisch zu beenden und genau
das will der UNO-Generalsekretär dass
das unterstützt worden ist das finde ich
gehört in einer Demokratie mit dazu dass
man unterschiedliche Vorstellungen hört
und sie wissen auch bei mir das ist
schon der Auffassung bin dass ich
dankbar bleibe für jede ernsthaftes
Bemühen dass wir humanitäre Feuerpausen
bekommen damit wir den Zivilisten vor
Ort auch helfen können mit humanitären
Maßnahmen und wenn das da zu dient was
sehr guterisch der Generalsekretär der
Vereinten Nationen auf den Weg bringt
verdient das jede Unterstützung und
Stimmen aus der Bundesregierung waren
dazu sehr selten gewesen umso wichtiger
ist dass sich auch Parlamentarier zu
Wort melden
ihr haushaltswoche beginnt
formell am Montag wo die Fraktion dann
auch zusammenkommen und sie wissen ja
auch es gibt manche Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die sich gern die Nacht um die
Ohren schlagen da gibt es
unterschiedliche Vorlieben ich muss
sagen ich möchte sehr konzentriert an
einer solchen Entscheidung mitwirken
war das Thema Strom macht Design ein
wichtiges Thema bei den Beratungen aus
ihrer Sicht kann Deutschland alleine
das Design ändern oder muss das
europäisch gemacht werden wie sich das
schnell überhaupt machen und werde damit
dann auch eventuell eine
übergewinnsteuerung gucken ich bin sehr
für ein europäischen weg und ich glaube
hier hat auch sowohl die Kommission und
insbesondere die kommissionspräsidentin
Aufgaben zusammen natürlich mit den
Kommissaren
auf der anderen Seite ist es ganz
wichtig dass wir verschiedene
Instrumente auch nutzen um auf die
Herausforderungen einzugehen erst seit
den vergangenen Tagen wird auch zur
Kenntnis genommen welche Unwuchten sich
auch auf dem sogenannten Strommarkt
bemerkbar machen umso wichtiger scheint
mir zu sein dass wir auch als
sozialdemokratische Stimme in dem Sinne
wahrgenommen werden wir haben immer
darauf hingewiesen dass der Markt das
nicht richten kann wir sind manchmal
belächelt worden in den vergangenen
Jahren umso wichtiger erscheint mir
zurzeit eine politische Diskussion
darüber zu sein dass wir uns nicht auf
Marktmechanismen verlassen können
sondern dass wir auch Eingriffe
letztlich brauchen gleichzeitig haben
wir in unserem Papier was die
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion letzte Woche
Sonntag auf den Weg gebracht hat und was
wir dann abschließend hier auch beraten
eine Diskussion beeinflussen wollen dass
wir nicht nur über die Energie Gas
gesprochen haben sondern eben auch über
den Strom dass wir auch hier
Regulierungen brauchen und wir wollen
überhaupt nichts vom Tisch nehmen ich
finde wichtig dass die übergewinnsteuer
wenigstens von uns in die Diskussion
gebracht worden ist weil wir brauchen
auf der einen Seite eben auch Entlastung
der Bürger aber auf der anderen Seite
auch eine Diskussion um Gerechtigkeit
und wenn es Mitnahmeeffekte gibt von
eben Akteuren auf dem Markt innerhalb
von Unternehmen dann muss das gebremst
werden und ich glaube ein Angebot ist
gemacht worden und ich bin sehr dankbar
dass der spanische Ministerpräsident bei
seinem Besuch der Kabinettsklausur aus
Spanien mal auch
dem einen oder anderen deren
Kabinettstisch sitzt erklärt hat was die
übergewinnsteuer möglicherweise auch an
positiven Effekten hat und vielleicht
landet ja seitdem auch ein Umdenkprozess
statt
[Musik]
mit der Abschaltung der des
renditeautofiloten oder könnten sie sich
das doch vorstellen und noch einmal eine
Nachfrage zum koalitionsoffen weil wie
gesagt kann ausgeruht und möglichst
keine nachsitzung nach den Termin des
Bundeskanzlers Liebe nur der Samstag das
ist falsch
Frau Dunst erstmal vielen Dank und ich
will auch sagen dass ich jeden Vorschlag
insbesondere der die auch Dinge aufnimmt
die wir ja politisch mit bestimmten
Instrumenten auch in die Diskussionen
bringen die der Finanzminister
möglicherweise uns mit an die Hand gibt
bedenkenswert sind ich glaube er hat ein
breites Portfolio auch zur Verfügung und
wir sehen ja auch in den letzten Stunden
dass sich vielleicht manche Äußerung für
den ein oder anderen überraschend aber
dann doch offener gibt als sie in den
vergangenen Tagen gewesen sind deswegen
nehme ich das sehr gerne auf ich werde
aber in der öffentlichen Diskussion
nichts zu Kompromissen sagen es geht
nicht am Ende um Kompromisse sondern es
geht um kluge Entscheidungen die auch
nur diese Koalition auf den Weg bringen
kann wenn ich mir eben vorstelle was
Oppositionsfraktionen in den letzten
Wochen jeden Tag unterschiedlicher Art
gesagt haben
zeigt sich der qualitative Unterschied
dass am Ende das Ergebnis zählt und wenn
der Finanzminister dazu Beiträge gibt
werden wir die sehr intensiv und das tun
wir auch in diesen Stunden und Tagen
auch diskutieren und am Ende zählt das
Gesamtergebnis vielleicht kennen Sie den
Terminkalender des Bundeskanzlers noch
besser als ich wenn Sie daraus schließen
dass nur der Samstag bleibt mag das sein
aber es zählt ja auch der Kalender von
anderen die mit am koalitionstisch
sitzen und von daher werden wir schon
eine terminlücke bei allen finden
noch entscheidend sein wo die eine Frage
und
die andere Frage halten sich für denkbar
dass es gerade die Koalitionsausschuss
nicht zu einer ankommt naja die Kalender
von allen die erstmal dort am Tisch
sitzen sie wissen dass die anderen
Koalitionsparteien mit einer
größeren Gruppe mit einer größeren
Gruppe kommen wir sind sehr konzentriert
sowohl in der Diskussion als auch von
der Personenzahl bei uns können Sie die
Kalender gut übereinander legen und aber
dennoch finde ich der
Koalitionsausschuss ist das Gremium der
Koalitionsparteien die haben den
Koalitionsvertrag verhandelt auch
entschieden auf dem Parteitagen
beschlossen deswegen geht es nicht nur
alleine um Kabinettsmitglieder und auf
der anderen Seite ich bin immer der
Meinung dass durch Konzentration wie
Ergebnisse finden und deswegen will ich
einfach sagen ich möchte einen Erfolg in
diesem Koalitionsausschuss und keine
nichtergebnisse
Transformation vor Ort zu sehen es ist
die Stimmung und Ausbildung als die
Sanktionen und die Konsequenzen angeht
anders als Investment also viele vor Ort
tragen tatsächlich die Konsistenzen wir
wollen die Konsequenzen nicht mittragen
wenn es an einen Geldbeutel geht wie
wollen sie als SPD denn die Leute hier
vor Ort überzeugen dass diese
funktionsmaßnahmen sinnvoll sind und
dass sie auch wirklich nicht so gern
lassen sind und damit dann nicht auch
andere Parteien die du als AFD zum
Beispiel ja hier gewinnen
sehen und das will ich vielleicht
einfach noch mal betonen wir scheuen
eben nicht das Gespräch sondern wir sind
ganz bewusst hier hingegangen es gab
auch Bedenken teilweise auch aus anderen
Umgebungen warnungen davor wir wissen
auch dass es möglicherweise zu
öffentlichen Protesten am Rande unserer
hier Sitzung kommt
aber wir fürchten eben nicht auch das
Gespräch wenn es angenommen wird wir
wollen aber auch insbesondere mit
denjenigen die sich eben nicht in
Protesten anschließen eine
Unterstützung aber auch unseren Respekt
geben und dazu zählen nicht nur die
Zivilorganisationen die hier vor Ort
tagtäglich wir reisen dann wieder ab
eben auch ihre Stimme erheben die
Demokratie mit unterstützen wollen
sondern wir wollen eben auch gerade den
Unternehmen und den Arbeitnehmerinnen
und Arbeitnehmer die sich hier eben
nicht nur angesiedelt haben sondern wo
auch Arbeit nachgefragt wird eine
Unterstützung durch unsere Anwesenheit
geben deswegen besuchen wir Sie auch
aber wir wollen auch gesetzgeberische
Maßnahmen mit auf den Weg bringen der
letzten Legislaturperiode ist es uns
nicht gelungen dass
demokratiefördergesetz mit auf den Weg
zu bringen alles das sind jetzt Dinge
die wir glaube ich in dieser Koalition
auch besser machen und auch mit Mitteln
auch letztlich ausstatten und das ist
ein langer Weg Professor die Frau
Professor grande die wir heute morgen
von der TU Chemnitz bei uns hatten hat
uns noch mal ermutigt auch zu sagen sie
war zum Beispiel für eine gewisse Zeit
in Westdeutschland gewesen zur
Ausbildung sie ist ganz bewusst auch
hierhin zurückgekehrt und sie sagt viele
jüngere viele Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer aber auch Studierende
suchen ganz fest den Platz hier in den
ostdeutschen Bundesländern und das hat
mich sehr gefreut und das wollen wir
stärken
damit sie nicht noch mal eine Frage zu
übergewinn steuern die wird ja in ihrer
Partei sehr positiv diskutiert jetzt hat
der Kanzler aber auf seiner Sommer
Bundespressekonferenz gesagt diese stehe
gar nicht im Koalitionsvertrag und sei
zudem technisch herausfordernd wie passt
das zusammen nun da hat er recht aber es
ist natürlich so dass sowohl der
Parteivorsitzende Lars Klingbeil als
auch wir von Seiten der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion eine
perspektivische Diskussion wollen wir
wollen in Deutschland eben auch darüber
informieren dass das dann kein Sonderweg
wie er immer unterstellt wird von Seiten
Deutschlands wäre sondern auch andere
europäische Länder Regierung Parlamente
haben sie längst eingeführt haben dort
unterschiedliche Erfahrungen mitgemacht
aber was wir wollen ist eine Diskussion
um Gerechtigkeit und das spüren ja die
Menschen wenn jetzt eben die Spritpreise
wieder hochgehen und das ist ja auch
schon vorher passiert bevor der
Tankrabatt ausgelaufen ist das eben
Unternehmen in einer krisenhaften
Situation bereit sind auch noch Gewinne
sozusagen über staatliches Handeln
zusätzlich abzuschöpfen das finden wir
ungerecht das versuchen wir mit der
übergewinnsteuer zu beantworten wir
wollen aber auch dokumentieren dass der
Staat durchaus Möglichkeiten bekommen
muss in den nächsten Monaten und Jahren
wo die Herausforderungen nicht geringer
werden wahrscheinlich auch noch mehr
Mittel braucht und deswegen auch diese
Diskussion geführt
langjähriger SPD man sozusagen das
Gefühl dass er tatsächlich etwas
auseinanderbricht
ich habe schon das Gefühl dass
unsere Gesellschaft
unser Land sehr verunsichert ist nicht
nur allein durch die Herausforderung der
letzten Jahre der Pandemie sondern auch
durch ein beispiellose militärische
Aggression wieder mitten in Europa und
auf der anderen Seite eine Situation wo
man meint man könnte sie nicht mehr
eingrenzen umso mehr müssen wir aber auf
der anderen Seite auch versuchen
deutlich zu machen dass es eben nicht
alleine der Markt richtet sondern am
Ende kluge Politik wo wir auch mit
Gesetzen auch letztlich eingreifen aber
auch mit finanziellen Mitteln und auf
der anderen Seite auch für eine
Gerechtigkeit innerhalb eines Landes
Sorgen was ja immerhin nach einem
unveränderlichen Grundgesetz Artikel ein
demokratischer Sozialstaat sein soll und
das wollen wir auch erhalten
also mein Name ist René Naumann von
Antenne 3 und was mich interessiert was
man in den sozialen Medien auch immer
wieder links zwischen Mann spricht von
einem heißen Herbst und von einem
hutwender die
Ängste der Menschen bezieht sich ja
darauf durch die explodierenden Energie
und Spritpreise haben Sie Ideen oder
werden sie
Maßnahmenpakete schnüren die die Bürger
letztendlich entlasten
wir wollen zu Entlastungen kommen und
das haben wir
vergangenen Sonntag mit der Präsentation
unseres
umfangreichen und das ist ja nicht
einfach an einem Tag entwickelt worden
sondern eben während der Sommerpause
Paket entwickelt weil wir nämlich
glauben dass das dritte Entlastungspaket
die ersten waren glaube ich wichtig
gewesen um auch breite sorgen aber auf
der anderen Seite auch einzuwirken in
eine Stimmungslage dass das dritte Paket
eben zielgerichtet sein soll und das hat
gestern ist er gerade daran erinnert
worden auch der Finanzminister
aufgenommen worden ich bin sehr froh
darüber dass die stärkste
Regierungsfraktion auch ein Gewissen
Takt vorgeben konnte wir haben
Rentnerinnen und Rentner wir haben
Auszubildende Studierende aber eben
insbesondere Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer und deren Familien mit
kleinem oder geringem Einkommen genannt
und natürlich auch transfer-
Ende alles an Sorgen nehmen aber eine
gewisse finanzielle Kompensation die
auch in diesem Haushaltsjahr für 2022
möglich ist die können wir gehen und
müssen auch Chancen daraus ergreifen
auch das für die nächsten Monate so
stabil zu machen dass die Menschen sich
wenigstens einigermaßen sicher fühlen
vor einem Winter den wir sowohl von den
Temperaturen nicht voraussehen können
als auch von dem
gesellschaftspolitischen Umfeld
einstelliger Milliardenbereich der jetzt
in diesem Haushalt ja zur Verfügung
steht reicht das wirklich aus und da in
diesem Jahr noch eine große Entlastung
oder ein entlastungsfakultät mit Druck
laufen wegzubringen und dann die Frage
ist unterwegs werden soll das egal ist
wahnsinnig viel Geld also lieber Gewinn
Steuer für sie ja Perspektive schenkbar
aber sie ziehen jetzt nicht so als
hätten den wieder große Chance für die
gegen die FDP durchzubringen sollte
jetzt entlastungsfall geht dann Schulden
finanziert werden soll Unverteilt werden
oder soll dann anderer Stelle dann
steuerlich werden also ich glaube das
ist dass ich sehr
aufmerksam und ich bin da sehr froh dass
der Finanzminister Wege eröffnen will
seit einigen Tagen und nicht sagt
alleine das kommt nicht das geht nicht
sondern dass er von einem wuchtigen
Paket spricht vielleicht ist der
Finanzminister wenn er den Begriff der
Wucht nimmt anders in der Inter Aktionen
als wir das sind aber wir finden schon
dass auf der einen Seite aus einem
Haushalt für 2022 noch durchaus Mittel
bereitstehen ich habe heute und auch in
den vergangenen Tagen andere Instrumente
angeboten wenn das nicht ausreicht wir
können auch gerne über einen
Nachtragshaushalt diskutieren wir haben
aber auch die Möglichkeit über bestimmte
andere Mechanismen die wir im
Grundgesetz verankert haben auch den
finanziellen Bereich des Staates zu
bereichern wenn ich das mal so
formulieren darf also kurz um es
scheitert nicht glaube ich am Ende daran
auch Wege zu wagen sondern es geht jetzt
darum das zielgerichtet zu machen und
wenn wir anfangen auch gerade für
November Dezember mit weiteren
Entlastungsmaßnahmen voranzugehen
entwickelt sich auch etwas in das Jahr
und wir stehen in der nächsten Woche vor
den ersten Beratungen und am Ende muss
ich sagen entscheidet der Gesetzgeber
über den Haushalt und das wird dann im
Dezember diesen Jahres finde ich ein
ganz gutes Signal dann für nächstes Jahr
auch sein
ich habe noch eine Frage zum
Strukturwandel auch angesichts des
Treffens morgen vom bundeswasser Scholz
mit dem Ministerpräsidenten es gibt ja
auch heute reisen an die Region
es gibt glaube ich in der Regionen das
Gefühl dass diese fördermilliarden die
zugesagt sind nicht den Effekt haben den
sie haben wollten das mindestens schnell
genug ist an der basisziplin in den
Kommunen das ist keines auf dem
glaskanzleien der Länder zu hören warum
soll es ja morgen gehen haben sie aus
Sicht der Bundestagsfraktion da auch das
Gefühl dass möglicherweise in Berlin den
Ministerien nicht das umgesetzt wird was
die eigentlich in der letzten mit dieser
beschlossen haben und für Vorwand und
die Förderung angeht
diese Stimmen die sie wahrgenommen haben
hören wir auch insbesondere natürlich
meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen die aus
diesen Wahlkreisen kommen
aber einen sozusagen zu identifizieren
an dem es scheitert hielte ich auch für
eine
belastbare
Fehleranalyse falsch wir haben Mittel
auch zur Verfügung gestellt ich glaube
dass auch der Strukturwandel so wie ich
ihn eben kenne ich komme aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen aus dem Rheinland
nicht direkt aus dem Ruhrgebiet aber das
ist ja nicht weit davon entfernt war ja
auch immer gewesen dass man das nicht
innerhalb von Wochen und Monaten
letztlich wird beantworten können aber
wir sehen schon dass diese Entscheidung
auch hoffentlich eine zusätzliche
Sicherheit auch für die Bundesländer
gegeben haben wir wollen eng mit den
Landesregierung aber insbesondere auch
mit den kommunalpolitisch
Verantwortlichen
nachjustieren wo möglicherweise auch
Stellschrauben nicht richtig angedreht
worden sind und dazu dient natürlich
dann auch die Diskussion mit dem
Parlament es bringt am Ende nichts dass
man sich nur beschwert sondern ich biete
an mit unseren Abgeordneten die Sie in
diesen Bereichen fachlich aber eben auch
aus der Örtlichkeit kennen wenn es
einzelne Probleme gibt auch damit zu
befassen und dann versuchen wir sie so
gut wie möglich auch abzustellen
vielen Dank und bleiben Sie gesund und
guten Aufenthalt hier Dankeschön ja das
war Rolf Mütze nicht der Fraktionschef
der Sozialdemokraten im Deutschen
Bundestag live aus Dresden zur Klausur
seiner Fraktion an diesem ersten
September und damit herzlich Willkommen
zu Phoenix vor Ort am Nachmittag wir
haben weitere Pressekonferenzen zu
diesen Sitzungen die diverser Fraktion
unter anderem CSU und CDU die Grünen
erwarten wir noch das ist die Zeit wo
sozusagen bilanziert wird was ist
vorgefallen in der Sommerpause was sind
jetzt die politischen Notwendigkeiten
und wie soll es anders sein vieles dreht
sich natürlich um die Situation rund um
den Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine
und den Folgen für uns alle das sind ja
die Energie- und Gas und Strompreise die
jetzt in Rede stehen und es geht um die
Frage welche Maßnahmen werden denn jetzt
wann ergriffen dagegen etwas zu
unternehmen bei mir im Studio an diesem
Donnerstagnachmittag ist Professor Karl
Rudolf Korte Politikwissenschaftler der
Uni Dortmund der Uni Duisburg Essen
bitte um Verzeihung Duisburg essen so
viel Zeit muss sein Herr Professor Korte
wir haben ja Mütze nicht gerade gehört
den Fraktionschef er spricht noch vom
Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine aber
sonst ist in diesen Tagen auch aus
Meseberg verhältnismäßig wenig dazu zu
hören in diesen Tagen warum drängt der
Krieg jetzt bereits so in den
Hintergrund ja Gewöhnung offenbar und
auch die Idee Einfluss darauf zu nehmen
doch zu verhandeln existiert offenbar
nicht mehr zumindest wird sie nicht
stark vorgetragen und eigentlich müsste
das der Ausgangspunkt auch einer
Klausurtagung in Meseberg sein denn alle
Themen ranken sich darum aus dem Krieg
letztlich auszusteigen und damit auch
Wohlfahrt Wohlstand in eine andere Bahn
energie-koalition ursprünglich ja mal
vor hat also
handelt man so dass am Ende wie auch
beteiligt werden an einer Verhandlung
die Krieg zu beenden darum muss es doch
letztlich gehen nicht nur um täglich
Menschenleben zu retten sondern auch die
die Ziele die die Bundesregierung hat
umsetzbar zu machen wo ist die
offizielle Position ja der
Bundesregierung vor allem von Frau
bärbock ja die das entscheiden die
Ukraine wann ob und wann verhandelt wird
und viele sagen ja was sollen wir mit
diesem Despoten mit diesem Diktator
verhandeln in dieser Situation so lang
er noch Bomben und Raketen abschießt auf
die Ukraine und das ist ja auch eine
verständliche Position der Ukraine das
zu überlassen ist stellt sich auch die
Frage welche Rolle überhaupt Deutschland
spielen könnte mindest drei kann es doch
nicht geben oder das vermute ich nicht
aber im Kontext der NATO spielen wir
natürlich eine sehr große Rolle wir
liefern Waffen und ohne diese liefernen
Waffen auch aus Deutschland wer der
Krieg überhaupt nicht führbar alle die
Waffen liefern müssen auch ein Konzept
haben denke ich an verhandlungs-
zu werden am Ende um eine friedlichen
Lösung
entgegenzukommen dass das schwierig ist
dass das unwahrscheinlich scheint ist
ist so aber ich will es einfach nur mal
vor der Klammer sagen das ist viel
wichtiger zunächst auch diese Frage zu
beantworten wir reden gleich weiter Herr
Professor Korte jetzt wollen wir
zunächst schauen was die Grünen zu sagen
haben denn die melden sich aus Potsdam
ja meine Damen und Herren
zweieinhalb Tage Beratung unserer
Klausur des Fraktionsvorstandes die erst
das erste Mal als Regierungsfraktion
in dieser
Legislaturperiode und ich will beginnen
damit
dass die Nachricht vom Tod von Hans
Christian Ströbele uns alle sehr traurig
gemacht hat Hans Christian Ströbele war
für uns ein Freund ein politischer
Weggefährte und eine der Figuren von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
dementsprechend ist gestern die
Nachricht von seinem Tod auf unserer
Fraktionsklausur hier auch eingeschlagen
das ist ein sehr trauriger Tag
ströbi ist einfach ein ganz ganz
junger Mensch gewesen ein solch
integrierer Mensch und wir alle haben
Erinnerungen an die Arbeit mit ihm an
das zusammen an sein mit ihm und wir
sind ganz sicher ströbi du wirst uns
unglaublich fehlen
meine Damen und Herren wir haben dann
natürlich über die Frage der
Herausforderung in diesen Tagen und
Zeiten gesprochen allen voran die
Energiesicherheit die Frage der
Versorgungssicherheit die Bekämpfung der
Klimakrise diese
krisenüberlagerungen mit Corona und dem
Angriffskrieg von Putin auf die Ukraine
und diese Situation verlangt diese
Regierungsbündnis sehr viel ab aber es
verlangt vor allen Dingen den Menschen
in der Gesellschaft den Unternehmen der
Wirtschaft allen insgesamt viel ab denn
wir müssen Sorge leisten dafür
dass die Energiesicherheit die
Versorgungssicherheit die Energiepreise
dass wir Antworten geben darauf mit
Entlastung die zielgenau wirken dass
Menschen nicht das Gefühl haben sie
werden allein gelassen und Sorgen und
Nöte vor Abstieg und Armut Raum greifen
die Menschen müssen sich darauf
verlassen können dass wir als
ampelbündnis Antworten in dieser
Krisenzeit geben und das stand im
Zentrum unserer Beratung die zeitenwände
sozial und ökologisch und nachhaltig
gestalten darum geht es jetzt und ganz
zu Beginn steht natürlich jetzt sehr
zeitnah in der Ampel am besten
vor Beginn der Sitzungswoche in der
nächsten Woche in der wir den Haushalt
beraten
uns als Ampel zu verständigen auf
zielgenaue Entlastungsmaßnahmen für
Menschen die wenig haben die sehr
betroffen sind dazu gehören
Grundsicherungsempfänger in dazu gehören
Menschen mit kleinen Renten Menschen mit
kleinen Einkommen und Familien mit
Kindern und hier gilt es jetzt Lösungen
zu finden und Vorschläge zu machen und
sich in der Ampel darauf zu verständigen
auch darüber haben wir bei der Klausur
intensiv debattiert
wir sind als Ampelkoalition gefordert
eine Antwort auf diese Krise zu geben
die der tatsächlichen Größe der Krise
auch gerecht wird das heißt auf der
einen Seite zielgerichtet Menschen zu
unterstützen die aufgrund der hohen
Heizkosten vielleicht nicht mehr wissen
wie sie am Ende des Monats ein Geschenk
für den Kindergeburtstag kaufen sollen
das heißt aber auch in den Blick zu
nehmen was das gesamtwirtschaftlich
bedeutet wenn so viele Menschen auf
einmal aufgrund der hohen Energiepreise
zu wenig Geld haben
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler waren davor
dass das Land in eine konsumgestützte
Rezession abrutschen könnte und deswegen
ist es notwendig dass das
Entlastungspaket was wir als Ampel
vereinbaren wollen diese Herausforderung
adressiert eine entsprechende Größe hat
mit der die Menschen zielgenau mit
geringen Einkommen denn um diese geht es
auch unterstützt werden
und wir müssen gleichzeitig und das
heißt der Größe der Krise gerecht zu
werden die zweite noch schneller
voranschreitende Krise adressieren das
ist die Klimakrise wir haben das in
diesem Sommer überall in unserem Land
gesehen was es bedeutet wenn die
Klimakrise beginnt und deswegen sagen
wir Grünen ganz klar wir erteilen
Maßnahmen eine Absage die eine Klima
schädliche Wirkung hat und wir
konzentrieren uns mit unseren
Vorschlägen auf Maßnahmen die doppelt
nutzen einmal gut für das Klima sind und
auf der anderen Seite sozial gerecht
sind und wir freuen uns sehr dass es in
der Koalition offensichtlich beginnt
sich eine Einigkeit abzuzeichnen bei der
Frage der Verlängerung eines neuen
euro-tickets nachfolgetickets wir Grünen
haben sehr lange dafür geworben dass das
9 euro-ticket nicht einfach auslaufen
darf das ist jetzt auch in der FDP
Unterstützung für diesen Vorschlag gibt
das freut uns sehr
aus unserer Sicht ist wichtig dass ein
solches Ticket nicht nur bundesweit gilt
und damit einfach ist für die Menschen
sondern dass es gleichzeitig auch ein
niedrigen Preis hat damit wirklich
Teilhabe für alle an diesem Ticket auch
ermöglicht wird und auf der anderen
Seite müssen wir im Verkehrssektor
Vorankommen mit mehr kurzfristigen
Maßnahmen mit Blick auf das Thema
Klimaschutz und deswegen schlagen wir
den Abbau oder die Reform des
sogenannten Dienstwagen Privilegs vor zu
Finanzierung und das hätte eine doppelte
positive Wirkung auf Klimaschutz und
Gerechtigkeit
vielen Dank dann komme ich jetzt in
Fragen Frau Herzog sie habe ich schon
als erste gesehen
in den Verhandlungen und Gesprächen zu
Entlastungspaket ist jetzt ganz wichtig
dass wir zielgenau Entlastung
formulieren diese auf den Weg bringen
und zwar so schnell wie möglich alle
wissen dass im Oktober die gasumlage
kommt und gleichzeitig sind wir jetzt
gefordert als Ampel das Signal
auszugeben wir sehen die zusätzlichen
Belastung und es müssen konkrete
Entlastungsmaßnahmen kommen und deshalb
geht es jetzt darum im positiven Sinne
zu diskutieren wo genau setzen wir mit
Entlastung an bei Menschen die wenig
haben bei Menschen mit kleinen Renten
und dazu gehört dann sicherlich die
Reform des Bürgergeldes die aber im
ersten Schritt vielleicht auch einmal
Hilfen höhere Regelsätze oder aber auch
den Kinderbonus den Kinderzuschlag
umfasst alles ganz konkrete Maßnahmen
die schnell wirken müssen die kommen
müssen genauso wie die Diskussion
darüber dass wir das Wohngeld
reformieren den Heizkostenzuschuss
erhöhen oder aber sowas ganz
lebenspraktisches wie ein Moratorium für
Strom und Gas Sperren auf den Weg
bringen solche Dinge werden gebraucht
und darüber wird diskutiert und nicht im
Umkehrschluss darüber was könnten wir
ausschließen wichtig ist wie wir das
ganze finanzieren sie wissen dass wir
als Bündnis 90 die Grünen hierzu einen
Vorschlag gemacht haben mit der
übergewinnsteuer und meine Kollegin
Katharina dröge hat gerade schon die
Frage des
abbausumweltschädlicher Subventionen im
Hinblick auf den Abbau des
dienstwagenpriviles angesprochen alles
wichtige Punkte für uns inhaltlich und
sehr konkret und präzise realisierbar
wenn wir uns in der Ampel darauf
verständigen
Herr Hansen hat das richtig gesehen ja
bitte
gut
sterben wie viele Milliarden fast eine
entsprechende
wir haben wie Frau Hasselmann bereits
gesagt hat eine klare Auffassung der
Koalitionsausschuss sollte Tagen bevor
der Deutsche Bundestag in der nächsten
Sitzungswoche zusammenkommt ist es
wichtig dass wir uns als ampelfraktion
darauf verständigen mit welchen
Entlastungen wir dann auch in den Herbst
gehen die Menschen erwarten von uns dass
sie jetzt Klarheit darüber bekommen dass
sie zielgerichtet entlastet werden und
für uns gibt es damit Blick auf das
Finanzvolumen keine eine Maßnahme die
alles adressieren wird sondern wir
plädieren für unterschiedliche Maßnahmen
die zielgerichtet sind eine
energiepauschale beispielsweise würde
Menschen mit geringerem Einkommen mehr
unterstützen als mit hohem Einkommen
aber eben auch die Mittelschicht
erreichen Familien mit Kindern durch
eine Erhöhung des Kindergeldes und eine
Erhöhung der Regelsätze das wird mit
sicherlich mit Sicherheit nicht im
einstelligen Milliardenbereich sein
worauf sich die Koalition dort
verständigen sollte
deine hackenbruch Bitte
[Musik]
wir haben sehr klar gesagt und das war
mit Blick auf die Diskussion das cdu/csu
und andere vorgeschlagen haben man müsse
die Atomkraftwerke laufen lassen um das
Wärmeproblem in diesem Land zu lösen
dass das Unfug ist denn Atomkraftwerke
können maximal ein Prozent des
gasverbrauches der in der
Stromproduktion ist ersetzen und dafür
haben wir die Kohlekraftwerke aus der
Reserve geholt deshalb war das an dieser
Stelle eine Scheindebatte eine
ablenkungsdebatte wenn man sich jetzt
anguckt warum die Strompreise in die
Höhe gehen dann hängt das mit der Krise
der französischen Atomkraftwerke
zusammen in Frankreich ist mehr als die
Hälfte der Atomkraftwerke gerade nicht
im Betrieb deswegen müssen europäische
Nachbarländer in großem Umfang Strom
nach Frankreich
exportieren und deswegen sind die
Gaskraftwerke momentan mit in der
Stromproduktion weil es dort ein Mangel
gibt um im Blick auf die
Versorgungssicherheit in unserem Land
haben wir viele gute Vorschläge wie wir
noch zusätzliche Kapazitäten
mobilisieren können bei den erneuerbaren
Energien das ist praktikabel das geht
schnell das ist sicher beispielsweise
den Deckel bei der Biomasse zu heben den
Deckel bei Solar zu heben bei den
instandsbestandsanlagen und auch bei den
Windrädern die Deckel zu heben das sind
Maßnahmen die kurzfristig realistisch
und schnell gehen um mit Blick auf die
hohen Strompreise hat die
Bundesregierung ja bereits angekündigt
dass sie eine Reform vorschlagen wird
wie dies adressiert
dann einmal bitte der Herr vorne
[Musik]
wir haben als grüne keinen Hehl daraus
gemacht dass unsere Präferenz für das
zweite Entlastungspaket nicht beim
Tankrabatt lag und dass die
Wirkungsweise die sich manche davon
versprochen haben wir die nicht gesehen
haben und deshalb planen wir als Bündnis
90 die Grünen keine Verlängerung eines
tankrabatts
Herr Mühle bitte
die Ampel ist sehr gefordert angesichts
der krisenüberlagerung von Klimakrise
Corona und dem Angriffskrieg von Putin
auf die Ukraine mit all seinen Wirkungen
auf die Versorgungssicherheit die
Energieversorgung und das sehen wir in
diesen Tagen das wissen wir und deshalb
steht im Fokus für uns dass wir als
Ampel handlungsfähig sind und das
erwarten die Menschen von uns zu Recht
wir sind gewählt worden und haben uns
als Ampel zusammengeschlossen um dieses
Land nach vorne zu führen und um
Versäumnisse der letzten 16 Jahre der
Vorgängerregierung eben aufzuarbeiten
die Transformation nach vorne zu bringen
und viele viele Weichenstellungen sozial
und ökologisch auf den Weg zu bringen
und das erwarten die Menschen zu Recht
und sie war erwarten dass wir uns in
einer solchen Krisenzeit mit uns selbst
beschäftigen deshalb wir sind drei sehr
unterschiedliche Koalitionspartner mit
programmatischen Unterschieden wir haben
uns zu einem Bündnis zusammengefunden
hier kann es in solchen Krisenzeiten
auch mal Knirschen auch mal
unterschiedliche Auffassungen geben aber
was zählt ist das was wir politisch auf
den Weg bringen und darum geht es und
das erwarten Menschen zu Recht von uns
und da gehe ich davon aus dass alle drei
Koalitionspartner das wissen
Frau von Bouillon bitte
[Musik]
Industrie
durchsetzen könnte
ganz klar gesagt eine übergewinnsteuer
soll diejenigen Unternehmen adressieren
die leistungslose übergewinne machen das
heißt die nicht durch
Innovationsleistungen jetzt gerade
Rekordumsätze und gewinne haben sondern
die von der Krise profitieren und da
sagen wir ganz klar wir meinen dieses
Instrument ernst und wir meinen es
völlig unvoreingenommen dahingehend
welches Unternehmen das trifft wir
machen mit Sicherheit nicht Politik
danach dass wir uns aussuchen welches
Unternehmen uns gefällt oder nicht
sondern dieses Instrument trifft dann
alle die das Kriterium erfüllen und das
ist auch richtig so
zwei Fragen habe ich noch Herr
webermeier bitte
Stresstest wird ja wahrscheinlich nicht
drinstehen weiterlaufen lassen ja oder
nein sondern eben verschiedene Optionen
pro wäre denn für die Blumen im
Bundestagsfraktion der Punkt die sagen
okay dann lassen wir sie für eine
weitere das musst du da
wir haben sehr deutlich gemacht wir
wollen keine Laufzeitverlängerung und
wir werden jetzt den Stresstest abwarten
und auswerten wenn er kommt meine
Kollegin Katharina Drücker hat sehr
deutlich gemacht dass es jetzt darum
geht sehr viele Handlungsoptionen sehr
viele
Optimierungsmaßnahmen auszuschöpfen die
bislang nicht gezogen sind vom
Lastmanagement über die Biomasse über
die Frage der deckelbeseitigung bei
anderen erneuerbaren Energieträgern die
Frage von Energieeffizienz und
Energieeinsparung darauf fokussieren wir
uns auch in der Diskussion die wir hier
geführt haben
dann Herr dake bitte
in Deutschland nur staatlichen zu machen
Fraktionen fällt ja dadurch auf dass sie
sehr viele Vorschläge in der Opposition
macht diese im Regierungshandeln
umgekehrt gemacht hat das wäre so meine
Anmerkung dazu sie hat ja in der
Vergangenheit gerade zu einer
Privatisierung unserer Gasspeicher
beigetragen das waren die Entscheidungen
der Unionsfraktion in der Vergangenheit
und wir sorgen jetzt erstmal mit
sinnvoller Regulierung mit
mindestfüllspeicherständen dafür dass
die Versorgungssicherheit in diesem Land
mit Blick auf Gas besser gewährleistet
ist auch das eine Maßnahme die die
Unionsfraktion unter Wirtschaftsminister
Peter Altmaier unterlassen hat weil sie
es für zu teuer gehalten hat diese
mindestfüllstände vorzuschreiben das
hätte man auch im vergangenen Winter
schon machen können dann hätten wir
besser da gestanden und deswegen
korrigieren wir aus meiner Sicht sehr
pragmatisch die Fehler der Vergangenheit
und zum Schluss Herr Decker
wir sind wahrscheinlich alle einig dass
die Koalition jetzt in einem sehr
entscheidende Punkt ist was die
Entlastung und die gesellschaftliche
politische Lage in Deutschland angeht in
anderen Zeiten gibt es ja zumindest
theorietisch immer noch die Möglichkeit
für einen Koalitionspartei wenn sie mit
Ergebnissen Verfahren und nicht
zufrieden ist zu sagen ja dann geht's
halt mit der Regierung nicht weiter ist
das in der
angesichts des Krieges in der Ukraine
für sie zumindest eine theoretische
Option oder sagen Sie das geht auf gar
keinen Fall wir müssen so oder so bis
2025 durchhalten egal was politisch
sozusagen die Koalition beschließen
Verantwortungsübernahme ist für uns ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt gerade in dieser
Krisenzeit denn wer wenn ich Bündnis 90
die Grünen sollte denn die soziale und
nachhaltige zeitenwände gestalten und
das sehen wir doch bei den vielen
Vorschlägen die aus der Opposition
kommen die zum Teil vielleicht auch in
der öffentlichen Debatte angestoßen
werden durchtritte wir wollen dass die
Frage der Bekämpfung der Klimakrise die
Frage der europäischen Situation der
sicherheits- und Friedensordnung und
auch die Frage des sozialen
Zusammenhaltes in dieser Krisenzeit
eine Antwort findet diese zeitenwände
die nachhaltig ist und sozial und
deshalb tragen wir in dieser Situation
Verantwortung und ich bin jeden Tag froh
dass die Außenministerin dieses Landes
Annalena baerbock heißt und der Energie-
und Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
vielen Dank
und dann herzliche Einladung zum
Mittagessen genau wir freuen uns wenn
Sie die Einladung folgen vielen Dank
wünschen wir doch guten Appetit Richtung
Potsdam die zeitenwände ist ein stark
strapazierter Begriff in diesen Tagen
das war also live aus Brandenburg die
Pressekonferenz der Grünen
Fraktionsspitze zur Klausur der grünen
Bundestagsfraktion kurz bevor wir gleich
ausführlich über das was wir gehört
haben hier im Studio sprechen der
Hinweis um 13 Uhr erwarten wir von der
Zugspitze eine Pressekonferenz der Union
namentlich von Alexander Dobrindt und
Friedrich Merz das Bild von dort oben
vom höchsten Berg des Landes steht also
schon stabil also kann einer die
Pressekonferenz dann also pünktlich wenn
die beiden Herren pünktlich sind um 13
Uhr beginnen Professor Karl Rudolf Korte
hat sich jetzt auch die Pressekonferenz
der Grünen Fraktionsspitze angehört wie
alle anderen zuvor auch schon jetzt ist
mir aufgefallen da wird jetzt davon
gesprochen das dritte Paket was jetzt
schnell verabschiedet werden muss soll
zielgenau sein er fällt mir irgendwie
auf und ein waren die anderen das denn
nicht ja man hat immer wieder einen
Mangel festgestellt bei den Vorgängern
dass man bestimmte Berufsgruppen oder
Bevölkerungsgruppen vergessen hat oder
sie nicht ausreichend würdigt hat das
wird bei jedem Paket passieren jedes
Paket was als Sammelsurium daherkommt
wird sich dieser Kritik stellen müssen
sofern ist der große Wurf der vielleicht
in wesenburg besprochen wurde ohne dass
wir es bisher erfahren wurde erfahren
haben noch nicht ausgesprochen der muss
ja an einem narrativ sich orientieren
was nicht einfach an Lösungen auf
kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner passiert
sondern schon eine neue Dynamik in eine
neue Richtung darstellt vielleicht mit
Instrumenten die wir noch gar nicht
richtig kennen wenn ich dir handelnden
Politiker jedenfalls die Fraktionschefs
richtig verstanden habe auch Rolf
Mützenich wird es nicht mehr allzu lange
dauern gerade kam mir auch die Forderung
dass es vor der haushaltswoche die ja am
nächsten Dienstag beginnt vielleicht ein
Ergebnis gibt oder in der haushaltswoche
dann möglicherweise durch den
Finanzminister oder den Kanzler bekannt
gegeben wird die Grünen die
Fraktionsspitze hat gerade noch mal sehr
deutlich gemacht Atomkraft mit uns
Verlängerung der drei
Kernkraftwerke die noch am ADS Netz sind
kommt für uns nicht in Frage könnte das
Durchhalten in diesen schwierigen Zeiten
das habe ich jetzt auch anders
interpretiert sie beziehen sich ja auf
den Stresstest und warten das Ergebnis
erst ab eine grundsätzige
Begrifflichkeit mit einer Verlängerung
würden sie niemals mittragen aber eine
Möglichkeit zu Überbrückung aus der Not
heraus aus nationalen Sicherheitsgründen
für eine begrenzte Zeit schließlich
nicht aus dass die Grünen das mittragen
es kommt eben darauf an wie man
Krisenkommunikation betreibt dass das
entscheidend dass die Handlung die jetzt
notwendig sind konsistent erscheinen
auch uns gegenüber als Bürgerinnen und
Bürger darauf kommt es entscheidend an
und dann kann man auch ein Klima
schaffen das für Herbst und Winter die
Qualität dieser Demokratie erhält nicht
durch prä Situation einzelner
sammelsuriendarstellung nicht durch
entlasteritis sondern durch einen
konzeptionellen Entwurf den man durchaus
alle vier Wochen nachbessern nachsteuern
kann weil das Managen des
unwahrscheinlichen in der Zeit des
Gewissheit schones indem wir gerade
Leben da gibt es kein Masterplan 123 und
das Problem ist gelöst aber uns das so
zu erklären dass man daran arbeitet als
lernkoalition das wäre echte
Krisenkommunikation dass die Parteien
das jetzt so machen ist klar aber es
zeigt auch wie die kanzlerdemokratie
sich verändert das ist natürlich wichtig
dass die Fraktionen sagen sie
entscheiden letztlich im Bundestag über
das Geld aber wir haben bei einer Ampel
kurz Konstellation auch eine Veränderung
des nicht nur alles im Kanzleramt
entschieden wird das merkt man ja an
diesem Beiträgen heute morgen auch sehr
gut jetzt hat Rolf Mütze nicht vorhin
live aus Dresden ja darauf hingewiesen
dass es im Grundgesetz ein
Sozialstaatsgebot gibt das ist ja da
schriftlich fixiert warum macht ihr das
so deutlich diesem Moment ja weil alle
Maßnahmen ja in der Fahrt Treuheit
letztlich dieser Republik sich zu
orientieren haben die den sozialen
gesellschaftlichen Frieden auf hohem
Niveau sichert wie kann unter den
Leitprinzipien von Gerechtigkeit
Maßnahmen abgeleitet werden und nicht
willkürlich sondern den Zusammenhalt der
Gesellschaft zu behalten und die
Dramaturgie von Krisen kennen wir ja sie
hat dazu in den letzten Bundestagswahlen
bei unter Corona dazu geführt dass wir
überhaupt nicht mehr wissen wie Extreme
sind wir sind ja mittiger geworden wir
sind ja solidarischer geworden also in
der Krise sehe ich gar nicht das
Potenzial zum Wut zum Protest sondern
wenn wir genau wie Mützen nicht sagte
diesem Pfad befolgen Prinzipien der
Gerechtigkeit oder hier der
Nachhaltigkeit mit einpflegen und es
entsprechend kommunizieren ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit für realistischen
Optimismus sehr groß damit rechnet
offensichtlich Rolf Mütze nicht in
Dresden aber nicht errechnet ja
möglicherweise mit Protesten kann es
sein dass jetzt diese Koalition
vielleicht die Geister gar nicht mehr
los wird die sie selber gerufen hat
Volksaufstand und ähnliche
Formulierungen von Frau bärbock war das
glaube ich
kann ich habe so den Eindruck die
Politik wartet regelrecht darauf oder
ist nicht clever weil es liegt natürlich
an der Ampel selbst wie sie kommuniziert
ob sie konsistent etwas vorschlägt um so
etwas zu verhindern wenn wir verstehen
dass es fair gleichermaßen befristet für
alle so weitergeht und wenn wir auch
verstehen dass wir es in der Hand haben
und nicht irgendein anderer dann kann
das am Ende auch ohne eine
protestgeneration oder eine neue
vonstatten gehen sondern die Ampel ist
selbst in der Hand und dazu ist es
wichtig nicht so zu tun als könnte man
mit Pflaster kleben über diese Krise
kommt sondern schon wird es zu
Wohlstandsverlusten bei uns allen kommen
und das muss man begründen warum wieso
vielleicht befristet aber Herr Professor
Korte diese gasumlage in der Form wie
sie jetzt ja veröffentlicht wurde ist
doch nicht fair oder das sage ich jetzt
nicht weil ich Gaskunde bin und mit Gas
zu Hause auch noch kochen muss sondern
ist doch den glaube ich 40 oder 45
Prozent aller Haushalte gegenüber die ja
so handeln müssen auch nicht fair oder
denn es geht ja um die Politik des
ganzen Landes gegenüber Russland und
nicht nur mich als Gaskunden das stimmt
als Einzelmaßnahme wird das nicht fair
man muss das schon einbetten etwas
anderes und das ist fehleranfällig war
hat mir jetzt gesehen um auch danach zu
steuern auch das ist wichtig in der
Kommunikation zu sagen moderne komplexe
Gesellschaften sind fehleranfällig wenn
es darum geht Politik als Problemlösung
zu darzustellen wir müssen nachstellen
wir müssen darüber öffentlich reden dass
etwas vergessen werden kann das passiert
und das ist Teil von komplexen
Gesellschaften die sehr schwer viel
schwerer zu steuern sind
wenn sie jetzt sagen und ich würde das
mal als Appell auch interpretieren
ihrerseits dass der Zusammenhalt so
ähnlich wie in der corona-krise jetzt
gefordert ist heißt das jetzt im
Umkehrschluss wir haben ja vorhin den
Christian Dörr von den
Liberalen auch gehört das sozusagen die
Identitäten der Parteien ein Stück weit
nach hinten in die Kulisse verschwinden
müssen oder müssen die Parteien in diese
schwierigen Situation trotzdem versuchen
ihre Identität nach vorne zu stellen
nein erstmal richten die Parteien sich
auf ein eine Bundestagswahl in drei
Jahren erst ein also das kurzfristig
jetzt spielt ohnehin keine Rolle und da
hat man langenarten was bis dahin noch
passieren kann aber außer der FDP die
anderen beiden sind sehr stark von ihren
traditionellen Ideologien komplett
abgewichen unter den Bedingungen der
Zeiten wenn er die FDP am wenigsten
insofern erleben wir ja Parteien die
sehr pragmatisch sich neu aufstellen und
mit dem was im Wahlprogramm drin stand
gar nichts mehr zu tun haben das kommt
gut an weil das praktisch eine sichtbare
Reaktion ist auf Krise angepasst zu
reagieren bevor wir weitersprechen der
Professor Korte kurz der Hinweis liebe
Zuschauer wir warten im Prinzip auf die
Pressekonferenz von der Zugspitze von
Friedrich Merz und Alexander Dobrindt
dort ist das Livebild von da oben zur
Pressekonferenz zur Klausur der Fraktion
der Fraktionsspitze muss man genauer
sagen der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion das ganze
wird also in knapp vier Minuten erwartet
das ist ja sozusagen die haushaltswoche
die wir nächste Woche erwarten ist
sozusagen markiert das Ende des
sogenannten politischen Sommerpause und
zur Vorbereitung dieser haushaltswoche
treffen sich eben drei um die Fraktion
um das ganze zu besprechen und ihre
politischen
Positionierungen vorzunehmen Herr
Professor Korte vielleicht kommen wir
jetzt mal zur Union die erwarten wir ja
gleich wie schwer oder wie leicht ist es
für Friedrich
seine Union in dieser Situation zu
positionieren in dieser Krisensituation
beides ist leicht und schwer leicht ist
es weil sie erstmals nach vielen Jahren
wieder eine breite demokratische
Opposition im Deutschen Bundestag
darstellt und das sichert natürlich die
Qualität der Demokratie auch der
Argumentation das ist erstmal einfacher
schwieriger ist dass man durch die ein
oder anderen Dinge die passiert sind
auch daran erinnert wird was man
vielleicht selbst in Regierungszeiten
nicht erreichen kann möglicherweise an
die Bundeswehr und ähnlich ist zum
Beispiel insofern gibt es auch
Schwierigkeiten konstruktive
Oppositionen zu betreiben aber bislang
agieren sie durchaus kooperativ was die
milliardenkritikkredit der Bundes
gegenüber der Bundeswehr betrifft
Grundgesetzänderung und das honorieren
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in der Tat aus
nicht Fundamentalopposition sondern
kooperativ und der Bedingung von Krise
auch zu zeigen wir arbeiten mit um die
Krise zu bewältigen das ist eine
Gradwanderung aber auf dem Weg befindet
sich im Moment die Union
Fundamentalopposition in diesem Moment
nicht weil sich das nicht gehört in so
einer Krisensituation weil der
Machthaber im Kreml sich auf deutsch
gesagt kaputtlachen würde darüber oder
warum nicht entweder wäre es rein
besserwisserisch das kommt nicht gut an
oder es erinnert ein an die Taten die
man nicht getan hat in den
zurückliegenden Jahren in dem man mit
regieren konnte das fundamentale möchten
die Deutschen nicht sie sind
konsensorientiert sie wollen am liebsten
überall runde Tische haben es ist eine
umarmungsdemokratie geradezu und
Ausdruck dessen ist auch das Verständnis
von Opposition bei Umfragen wird immer
dokumentiert dass die Mehrheit der
Deutschen meint dass die Opposition
durchaus zu einem hohen Anteil mit der
Regierung zusammenarbeiten sollte als
Demokrat treibt dann das eigentlich die
Tränen in die Augen weil es kein
Verständnis ist von Opposition aber die
Wirkungsmöglichkeiten jetzt einer großen
demokratischen Oppositionspartei sind
viel größer als in zurückliegenden
Legislaturperiode jetzt kam was die
Zufriedenheit der deutschen mit dem
staatlichen Handeln angeht heute das
Ergebnis einer interessanten oder ich
finde jedenfalls ein bemerkenswertes
Ergebnis des deutschen Beamtenbundes
einer Umfrage nur noch 29 Prozent der
Menschen glauben dass der Staat wirklich
handlungsfähig ist und die großen
Probleme die wir jetzt ja alle zusammen
haben lösen kann was bedeutet das 29
Prozent im letzten Jahr waren es noch
mehr als 40 ja und in den
Vielstimmigkeit von Vorschlägen wundert
das Ei nicht aber der Grundsatz besteht
natürlich darin dass Vertrauen zu
Institutionen zunimmt wenn man ihn auch
Problemlösungskompetenz zuwilligt wenn
das offenbar nicht der Fall ist man den
Eindruck hat die Probleme lässt sich
durch Politik nicht lösen dann nimmt das
Vertrauen ab aber das ist eine
Momentaufnahme wir werden das eigentlich
qualifizieren können durch die Wahl in
Hannover die Landtagswahl in knapp fünf
Wochen und ich bin überzeugt auch hier
wird die Mitte stärker Schwäche was da
wieder beweisen würde dass das Vertrauen
in die demokratischen Parteien der Mitte
existiert jetzt hat ja Friedrich Merz
der Oppositionsführer der Vorsitzende
der Unionsfraktion den Kanzler sehr hat
kritisiert ach übrigens ich sehe jetzt
im Hintergrund Friedrich Merz und
Alexander Dobrindt wir reden gleich noch
mal weiter sind bereits im Nebel auf der
Zugspitze vor Mikrofone und Kameras
getreten und ich denke jetzt geht's los
von meiner Seite hier auf der Zugspitze
wir freuen uns dass wir mit dem
geschäftsführenden Fraktionsvorstand der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion im Wahlkreis
von Alexander Dobrindt diese
Klausurtagung zu Beginn der Zeit nach
der Sommerpause machen können wir werden
uns auf dieser Klausurtagung mit allen
aktuellen wirtschaftspolitischen
haushaltspolitischen energiepolitischen
außenpolitischen Themen beschäftigen und
wir hätten eigentlich erwartet dass wir
nach der Zeitabfolge dieser Woche
eine
ein wirkliches Konzept der
Bundesregierung vorgefunden hätten wie
sie denn in der
energiepreiskrise und wie sie auch in
der drohenden Rezession gedenkt
politisch zu handeln wir sind überrascht
und erstaunt darüber dass diese
Klausurtagung des Kabinetts über zwei
Tage
praktische ergebnislos zu Ende gegangen
ist außer der Ankündigung dass man ein
großes Entlastungspaket beabsichtigt im
September noch einmal zu verabschieden
und außer der Ankündigung dass es eine
Nachfolge für das 9-euro-ticket geben
soll ohne zu sagen welche Lösung denn
von der Bundesregierung vorgeschlagen
wird die ja auch immerhin mit den
Ländern abgestimmt werden müsste also
offensichtlich eine Menge Zeit vertan in
der Sommerpause mit viel Streitigkeiten
der Koalition
dieses Land bräuchte jetzt eigentlich
eine
handlungsfähige geschlossene Regierung
einen Bundeskanzler der sich auf seine
Koalitionspartner verlassen kann der
diese Regierung führt der das Land führt
und der vor allen Dingen offen
ausgetragenen Streit der
Koalitionspartner untereinander
versucht zu vermeiden das ist ihm nicht
gelungen es gibt Ereignisse aus der
Sommerpause die gerade zu erschütternd
sind ich will noch einmal an den
Auftritt von Olaf Scholz vor dem
Untersuchungsausschuss cum-ex in Hamburg
erinnern ein Bundeskanzler der sich auf
mehr als 50 Fragen die ihm dort gestellt
werden nicht erinnern kann zu einem
Sachverhalt der die Stadt Hamburg über
mehrere Jahre beschäftigt hat mit dem er
als Bürgermeister in Hamburg mehrfach
unmittelbar zu tun hatte weiß nicht mehr
worüber da gesprochen worden ist mit dem
Ergebnis dass die Steuerverwaltung
versucht hat eine
auch Steuernachforderung von 47
Millionen Euro verjähren zu lassen das
macht in Deutschland kein Steuerbeamter
und gerade in der Stadt Hamburg von der
man weiß dass sie eine wirklich
außergewöhnlich gut funktionierende
Finanzverwaltung hat die in der
Verantwortung mehrerer cdu-senatoren
stand passiert so etwas nicht dieser
Auftritt von Olaf Scholz in Hamburg war
bizarr und dann dieser Vorgang im
Kanzleramt mit dem Chef der
Palästinenserbehörde Herrn Abbas es ist
ein einmaliger Vorgang in der Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland das hier
offene Hass auf Israel
unzulässige Vergleiche mit dem Holocaust
angestellt werden und
diese unwidersprochen im Raum stehen
bleibt und der Bundeskanzler diesem Mann
zum Abschied auch noch die Hand gibt ich
bin geneigt zu sagen das wäre
keinem seiner Amtsvorgänger in dieser
Form passiert das belastet das Ansehen
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland in der
ganzen Welt das wird ihn immer wieder
begleiten wenn er auch zum Beispiel das
nächste Mal nach Israel reisen wird noch
einmal das hätte einfach nicht passieren
dürfen jedem von uns passieren Fehler
jeder macht Fehler aber es gibt Fehler
die in einem solchen Amt nicht passieren
dürfen und spätestens die Mitarbeiter
hätten es rechtzeitig bemerken müssen
und an Ort und Stelle korrigieren müssen
auch das ist nicht geschehen nun das ist
der Sommer die wenden uns dem Herbst zu
wir müssen Antworten geben auf eine
ganze Reihe von Fragen wir treten
zusammen im geschäftsführenden Vorstand
der Bundestagsfraktion um genau diese
Antworten zu erarbeiten ich kann Ihnen
zwei sozusagen vorweg nennen die wir
auch im Konsens bereits festgelegt haben
erstens wir
fordern die Bundesregierung auf jetzt
wirklich alle
Möglichkeiten auszuschöpfen der
Energieerzeugung in Deutschland alle es
darf auf keine
energieerzeugungsquelle mehr verzichtet
werden das betrifft natürlich Steinkohle
und Braunkohle das betrifft Wind und
Sonne selbstverständlich das betrifft
alle anderen Formen der regenerativen
Energien wie zum Beispiel Biomasse und
Wasserkraft aber das betrifft auch und
ganz ausdrücklich die Kernenergie wir
könnten mit Kernenergie mit den drei
laufenden Kernkraftwerken für 10
Millionen Haushalte die Stromversorgung
sichern wir könnten mit den drei
Kraftwerken die im letzten Jahr
stillgelegt worden sind und die
unverändert sofort wieder hochgefahren
werden könnten weitere 10 Millionen
Haushalte mit Sicherheit mit Strom
versorgen dies nicht zu tun ist nicht zu
verantworten wir würden das tun wenn wir
heute in der Regierungsverantwortung
stehen wir haben deswegen der
Bundesregierung ja auch angeboten eine
Sondersitzung des Deutschen Bundestages
bereits im August stattfinden zu lassen
damit man zum Beispiel neue Brennstäbe
bestellt und auch das Atomgesetz ändert
habt ihr die Bundesregierung nicht getan
das ist ihre Verantwortung zweitens wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass dieser
Mechanismus dieses sogenannten married
order Systems durchbrochen wird das
zurzeit die
Gaskraftwerke mit ihren Strompreisen den
gesamten Strommarkt in allen
erzeugungsquellen so nach oben treiben
dass die Kosten für die privaten
Haushalte und für die Unternehmen ins
unerschwingliche
hinauf gleiten wir werden darüber
sprechen auch mit Fachleuten in dieser
Konferenz unser Vorschlag wird sein
entweder in die eine Richtung oder in
die andere Richtung Gas herauszunehmen
oder alle anderen erzeugungsquelle
herauszunehmen aus dem Marit order
System damit wir diese Preisdynamik
durchbrechen die zurzeit alleine durch
die Gaskraftwerke ausgelöst wird und die
für alle anderen eben auch diese hohen
Strompreise auslöst und damit die hohen
Verdienste und die hohen Erträge in den
betroffenen Unternehmen auslöst das sind
zwei Themen mit denen wir uns heute
beschäftigen werden wir werden dann
morgen zum Ende der Klausurtagung noch
mal die Ergebnisse auch bekanntgeben
aber diese beiden Punkte kann ich glaube
ich vorweg schon sagen und ansonsten
freue ich mich wirklich sehr auf die
Diskussion mit den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus der Bundestagsfraktion und
würde gerne auch Alexander Dobrindt in
seinem Wahlkreis in seiner Heimat hier
noch die Gelegenheit geben ist auch
ergänzen zu sagen wir freuen uns lieber
Alexander dass wir hier in Deiner
schönen Heimat zu Besuch sein dürfen
zu Recht Applaus hier vom Publikum
ja sehr geehrte sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren die Unionsfraktion trifft sich
heute auf der Zugspitze zur Beratung
weil Deutschland braucht Zuversicht von
der Zugspitze statt der Mutlosigkeit aus
Meseberg
die Ampel Regierung hat nicht die Kraft
zu Entscheidungen deutschland braucht
aber Entscheidungen und die Ampel hat
jetzt schon wieder einen kompletten
Sommer verbummeln lassen und die
notwendigen Entscheidungen verschleppt
wir haben wieder festgestellt dass keine
Einsicht bei der ampelregierung
vorherrscht dass Deutschland ein großes
Energieproblem hat und nicht wie Herr
Harbig sagt nur ein gasproblem wir haben
veritables Energieproblem und es ist die
Aufgabe der Bundesregierung die Lösungen
dafür zu suchen aber auch dann zu
entscheiden die auf der einen Seite die
Kapazität deutlich erhöhen bei der
Energiegewinnung auf der anderen Seite
die notwendigen Entlastungen bieten für
die Familien die Haushalte in
Deutschland und das strommarkt-design so
anpassen dass es nicht zu irrwitzigen
Entwicklungen am Strom und Energiemarkt
kommt all das ist nicht entschieden
worden die Chance hat die ampelregierung
verstreichen lassen und deswegen ist es
so wichtig dass wir die klaren Vorgaben
auch geben für diesen Herbst die jetzt
notwendig zu Entscheidung anstehen nicht
Entscheidung riskiert am Schluss einen
kalten Winter und deswegen ja die
Kapazitäten die dringend ausgebaut
werden müssen da geht es nicht nur um
die Frage der Kohlekraftwerke und fragt
sich ja warum das jetzt auch schon
wieder so lange dauert
es geht natürlich auch um die Frage der
Kernenergie man hat langsam das Gefühl
dass hier bewusst auch der Stresstest
verschleppt wird möglicherweise auch
über einen anstehenden Wahltermin in
einem Bundesland hinaus das alles können
wir uns in Deutschland nicht erlauben es
braucht die Bestellung der Brennstäbe
nicht nur für die noch im Betrieb
befindlichen Kernkraftwerke sondern auch
für die bereits abgeschalteten drei
Kernkraftwerke um sie wieder betriebsfit
zu machen Oma die Energielücke zu
schließen es ist ja wahnwitzig an einer
Idee festzuhalten im Winter in einer
Zeit der größten Energieknappheit und
des größten Energieverbrauchs dann auch
noch einen Energieerzeuger die
Kernkraftwerke aus dem Markt
herauszunehmen also da ist eine
dringende Entscheidung gefordert und
dieses verschleppen dieses sogenannten
Stresstests ist nicht weiter akzeptabel
was die Entlastungen angeht wir stellen
heute fest wie die Energiepreise wieder
explodieren an den Tankstellen
wenn man sich die Preisentwicklung
anschaut an der Tankstelle beim Strom
bei der Wärme dann wird für viele
Familien sich die Frage stellen ob am
Ende eines Monats der Kühlschrank voll
oder leer ist darauf muss die
Bundesregierung eine Antwort geben und
deswegen schlagen wir vor jetzt schnell
eine entlastungsentscheidung zu treffen
3+1 3000 Euro für jede Familie plus 1000
Euro für jedes Kind um das Signal zu
geben niemand wird mit diesen
explodierenden Energiepreisen jetzt
alleine gelassen die Entscheidung muss
dringend von Seiten der Ampel kommen und
bei den
Spritpreisen auch dies deutlich zu sagen
es wird Zeit dass unser Vorschlag
aufgenommen wird nämlich die Steuern an
der Zapfsäule zu senken um dafür zu
sorgen dass auch dort der Sprit wieder
billiger wird jetzt dieses ewige Hin und
Her bei dem
Design inzwischen scheinen ja auch
einige Mitglieder der Bundesregierung
Experten im stromarktdesign zu werden
dann sollen sie aber auch Lösungen
präsentieren und nicht die Schuld auf
ihre Mitarbeiter im Ministerium
abzuwälzen ich finde es ein
ungeheuerlichen Vorgang dass ein
Bundeswirtschaftsminister sich hinstellt
und sagt naja er sei ja hier kein
Fachmann und hätte hier nur das was
Horden von Juristen ihm gesagt haben am
Schluss umgesetzt man fragt sich wer
diese Horten von Juristen sind das
können wir wohl nur die Mitarbeiter des
eigenen Hauses sein ansonsten soll er
bitte Offenlegen von welchen Lobbyisten
er sich da beraten hat lassen es wäre
dringend notwendig hier Klarheit zu
schaffen und jetzt eine Entscheidung zu
treffen das nicht durch das Gas durch
das immer teurer werde Gas am Schluss
der Strompreis immer weiter in die Höhe
schnellt deswegen dringend geboten das
Gas aus der Strompreise Bildung
herauszunehmen oder einen vergleichbaren
Weg zu wählen um schnell dämpfend auf
diese Entwicklung einzugehen ansonsten
wird Deutschland jeden Tag
ärmer nicht entscheiden dieser
Bundesregierung Verschleppen von
Entscheidungen durch die Ampel macht
Deutschland jeden Tag ein Stück ärmer
wir können uns diese Politik nicht mehr
leisten die sagen wir klar in Anlehnung
an das was Franz Münte Mehring mal
gesagt hat mit Oppositionen ist Mist wir
können klar sagen ob Position ist für
uns opportunity das was wir aber Leben
ist die Ampel ist Mist
gut es bleibt Zeit für ein paar Fragen
zuerst Herr Strauß von der Rheinischen
Post Schmerz wenn sie so über den
Bundeskanzler schimpfen würden sie dann
sagen dass der Bundeskanzler seinem Amt
noch gerecht wird und die zweite Frage
wie regierungsfähig und regierungsbereit
sind sie und die Union also der straußig
schimpfe nicht über den Bundeskanzler
sondern ich kritisiere sein Verhalten in
zwei sehr konkreten Situationen einmal
in der Aussage vor dem
Untersuchungsausschuss cumex und das
andere Mal in der Sache abas
ich bin an dem Abend
zufällig im Fernsehen hängen geblieben
in den Tagesthemen und habe dort ja es
gucke ich nicht jeden Abend war auch mal
im Urlaub und deswegen gucke schon mal
gar nicht jeden Abend aber ich habe es
gesehen und wieder mit Interesse und
habe dort einen Kommentar eines
kommunikationswissenschaftlers gesehen
der gefragt worden ist ob das
Kommunikationspannen sind und die
Antwort war das sind möglicherweise
nicht nur Kommunikationspannen sondern
man muss sich mittlerweile die Frage
stellen ob Olaf Scholz dem Amt des
Bundeskanzlers der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland wirklich gewachsen ist
ich hätte das jetzt von mir aus so noch
nicht formuliert aber seitdem ich das so
gehört habe geht mit dieser Gedanke
durch den Kopf und ich muss wirklich
sagen wenn solche Dinge passieren einmal
diese Erinnerungslücken also wenn er die
tatsächlich hat ist es für sich ein
Problem
zweitens dieser Auftritt mit Abbas
dann muss man wirklich nicht die Frage
stellen ob er der Lage gewachsen ist
oder nicht wenigstens Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeiter hat die darauf achten
dass so etwas nicht passiert noch mal
jeder von uns macht Fehler aber im Amt
des Bundeskanzlers einen solchen
schweren Fehler zu machen der auch in
der gesamten Weltöffentlichkeit
wahrgenommen wird lässt diese Zweifel in
der Tat aufkommen ich bin noch nicht so
weit das endgültige Urteil darüber
abzugeben zweite Frage war sagen Sie mir
noch mal im Stichwort wir ja sag mal die
Opposition von heute ist die Regierung
von morgen der Grundsatz gilt immer
wir bereiten uns natürlich auch auf die
Themen aktuell vor ich bin als
Parteivorsitzender der CDU darum bemüht
auch die Partei neu auszurichten das tun
wir aber die Union ist auch ausweislich
der Umfragen die wir vorliegen haben
heute am Tag regierungsfähig wenn die
Regierung heute scheitert sind wir
morgen bereit zu übernehmen und das ist
völlig klar ich werde trotzdem die Zeit
die diese Regierung noch im Amt ist
nutzen um insbesondere die CDU weiter in
den großen Themen unserer Zeit zu
entwickeln aber die Bundestagsfraktion
der cdu/csu ist heute am Tag in der Lage
zu übernehmen
Frau sie war schon Focus
e
gehalten und jetzt werden sie für eine
Verlängerung des tankrabatts oder werden
sie für ein anderes Modell und deine
breite Frage
und eine zweite Frage vielleicht könnten
wir uns noch ein bisschen was
der Entscheidung sagen das Ortes also
was warum sind wir hier
warum hat man sich für die Zugspitze
entschieden
für dich
zu ihrer ersten Frage das noch mal sehr
deutlich zu machen
wir haben gesagt dass der Tankrabatt zu
mir konzipiert war nicht ausreichend gut
funktioniert das hat sich auch in der
Vergangenheit gezeigt dass die
Milliarden die eingesetzt worden sind
nicht direkt bei den Verbrauchern
angekommen sind zumindest nicht in
vollem Umfang und deswegen unser
Vorschlag der Vergangenheit der der
richtige gewesen wäre der ist der der
jetzt auch gefordert wird und umgesetzt
werden muss wir müssen bei der Steuer
runter an der Zapfsäule wir haben eine
Vielzahl von Steuern Mehrwertsteuer
Mineralölsteuer Ökosteuer alles auf dem
Sprit drauf da gibt es genügt in
Spielraum an dieser Stelle runterzugehen
andere Länder in Europa haben das auch
gezeigt das hat eine direkte dämpfende
Wirkung auf den Spritpreis ich glaube
das ist zwingend notwendig an dieser
Stelle um auch Mobilität gerade auch im
ländlichen Raum bezahlbar zu halten es
ist einfach nicht verantwortbar und
schon gleich gar nicht fair dass diese
Bundesregierung die Ampel
welche offensichtlich darauf einigt dass
man im öffentlichen Personennahverkehr
der natürlich in den Städten ein
deutlich höheren Ausbau hat als im
ländlichen Raum dass man da
Entscheidungen trifft damit weiterhin
günstiges günstige Mobilität möglich ist
aber der ländliche Raum hier weiterhin
massiv benachteiligt wird das ist so
nicht aufrecht zu erhalten und deswegen
braucht es auch Entscheidungen an der
Stelle um an der Zapfsäule die Preise zu
senken und was den Ort hier anbelangt
wir waren uns sofort einig dass die
Unionsfraktion an der politischen Spitze
in Deutschland steht und deswegen gehört
sie auch an die Spitze in Deutschland
top of Germany hier auf die Zugspitze
und ich glaube wir haben deutlich
gemacht dass die Union mit den uns heute
vorgelegten Papier und den Punkten in
der Lage ist die größten
Herausforderungen in Deutschland zu
bewältigen und dass wir
entscheidungswillig und
entscheidungsstark und auch wenn
notwendig dann die Entscheidungen
treffen könnten wenn die Bundesregierung
dazu nicht mehr in der Lage ist dann
Herr Feld von der ARD bitte
sie wollen auf jeden Fall einen längeren
Betrieb und nicht erstreckbetrieb gucken
ob es reicht sondern dauerhaft und dann
daran anschließend die Frage ist denn
der Bau von neuen Kraftwerken für sie
eine Option der Dorin aus ihrer Partei
gab es ja zumindest eine Stimme die das
mal geäußert hat
soll ich mal ich fange mal an damit aber
gerne dann auch Alexander also zunächst
einmal ist der streckbetrieb Option
Nummer eins ein längerer dauerhafter
Betrieb die zweite Option und die dritte
Option wäre auch die wieder in
Betriebnahme der drei im letzten Jahr
stillgelegten Kraftwerke dafür müsste
man Brennstäbe bestellen wobei diese
Kernkraftwerke alle auch noch Brennstäbe
haben die wären in der Lage sofort
wieder ans Netz zu gehen das ist
technisch möglich das ist personell
möglich und das ist rechtlich möglich
die Frage wie lange hängt sehr davon ab
wie lange wir uns in dieser Energiekrise
befinden wir wollen nicht zurück in die
alte Kernenergie und das hier mal klar
und deutlich zu sagen wir wollen nicht
zurück vor 2011 sondern wir wollen nur
die Möglichkeiten der Energieerzeugung
die wir heute hätten mit diesen sechs
Kraftwerken nutzen um eben nicht in eine
Versorgungskrise hineinzuschlittern
übrigens eine Versorgungskrise die uns
im Winter 23 24 möglicherweise
mindestens genauso sehr droht wie im
Winter 22 23 also reden wir hier schon
über einen Zeitraum schon ein bis zwei
drei Jahren
die Frage von Neubau von Kraftwerken
stellt sich im Augenblick nicht wir
beobachten allerdings mit großem
Interesse was zum Beispiel in einigen
Ländern außerhalb Europas geschieht die
Behauptung dass die Kernenergie weltweit
im Niedergang sei und weltweit
abgeschaltet wird ist nachweislich
falsch es gibt vierte und fünfte
Generation von Kraftwerken die auf der
Welt entwickelt und gebaut werden ich
beobachte diese in diese Entwicklung
technologisch mit hohem Interesse habe
keine abgeschlossene Meinung dazu nur
wir sollten auch diese Option nicht von
vornherein aus rein ideologischen
Gründen ausschließen es könnte eine
Option sein zum Beispiel noch mal über
diesen duellflugreaktor zu reden zum
Beispiel über andere Formen der
Energiegewinnung aus Kernenergie bis hin
zur Kernfusion noch mal meine
persönliche Haltung zu diesem Thema ist
Deutschland darf jetzt nicht mehr
aussteigen sondern wir müssen mal ein
Land sein was wieder einsteigt auch und
gerade in moderne Energie
überzeugungstechnologien dann sieht der
Chef der Bundesnetzagentur macht
deutlich dass die Energiekrise nicht
nach diesem Winter erledigt ist er
spricht davon dass auch der nächste
Winter ähnlich schwer werden kann jetzt
mit meinen Worten nicht interpretieren
aber er spricht auch vom nächsten Winter
immer bei dem wir vor großen
Herausforderungen entstehen und keiner
kann sagen ob es danach beendet ist und
deswegen ist die Idee zu sagen mit einem
streckbetrieb löst man irgendein Problem
eine falsche der streckbetrieb der ja am
Schluss möglicherweise sogar dazu führen
kann dass die Strompreise weiter Streik
weiter steigen weil er ja nur die
Strommenge verteilt auf einen anderen
Zeitrahmen
kann möglicherweise sogar negative
Wirkungen haben es braucht also auf den
Preis das braucht deswegen eine klare
Entscheidung dass wir zusätzliche
Energie über die Kernkraft herstellen
und inzwischen ist es ja unstrittig dass
das geht es ist eine Frage des
politischen Wollens an dieser Stelle
alle Ausreden der vergangenen Monate es
würde nicht funktionieren weil weil weil
keine Mitarbeiter zur Verfügung stehen
keine Genehmigungen da werden keine
Brennstäbe zur Verfügung stehen alles
hat sich als falsch erwiesen und
deswegen es geht darum endlich diese
ideologische Grenze offensichtlich bei
den Grünen zu überwinden und dafür zu
sorgen dass wir wegkommen von dieser
Ideologie Energie oder der vermeiden
dieser Ideologie Energie und hin zu
Vernunft Energien kommen und sagen das
was notwendig ist in Deutschland muss
eben jetzt entsprechend auch zur
Verfügung gestellt werden und das heißt
auch die Kernkraftwerke weiter zu
betreiben und die Kernkraftwerke wieder
ins Netz zu geben und wir müssen uns
dann nicht streiten darum ob das jetzt
drei oder vier oder fünf Jahre sind wir
müssen jetzt aus dieser größten Not
erstmal der energieunsicherheit
herauskommen dann würde ich die letzten
beiden Fragen ganz gern kombinieren Herr
blank und dann Herr doll
beantworten
Strompreis verdienen und eine ganz
erlauben ernährt seine private Frage
kurz persönlich Frage an Sie vor drei
Wochen etwa haben wir ein
Schlüsselbeinbruch wie lange müssen sie
die Schlaufe noch tragen die sehen er
tut's noch weh können Sie schlafen
irgendeiner Form offensichtlich nötig so
wie das Modell jetzt gewählt wurde
scheint ganz offensichtlich inhaltliche
Menge zu geben Grab oder Artikel 26 bin
kein Jurist wie würden Sie dieses
Problem lösen
[Musik]
da fange ich an also
zunächst einmal
die persönliche Frage vielen Dank dafür
ich habe mir heute genau vor drei Wochen
ziemlich genau um diese Uhrzeit bei
einem Sturz der Schlüsselbein gebrochen
und ein paar Bände abgerissen bin
operiert worden in München in einer
Klinik der Operateur hat sich nach der
Operation bei mir entschuldigt dass er
hier oben eine Platte reingesetzt hat
und die mit sechs grünen Schrauben
befestigt hat so ich habe ihm gesagt
wenn sie das auch nicht zugenäht haben
dann sehe ich es ja nicht mehr also es
ist soweit so gut schlafen kann ich
nicht besonders gut es wird aber jeden
Tag besser und ich denke mal in drei
Wochen weiteren drei Wochen habe ich es
im Wesentlichen hinter mir volle
Belastung der Schulter wird noch ein
paar Wochen länger dauern aber ist zu
einem guten Weg ich bin einfach ein Hang
runtergestürzt und dann auf der Schulter
aufgeschlagen und durch die Trockenheit
war der Boden der normalerweise normaler
waldboden ist so hart dass ich eben
diesen Aufprall nicht so überstanden
habe wie das normalerweise der Fall
gewesen wäre okay also sowas kann
passieren erste Frage gehen Stichwort
übergewinnsteuer im also ich habe
Verständnis dafür dass diese windfall
profits die jetzt bei diesen Unternehmen
entstehen die von den hohen
Energiepreisen profitieren ohne dass sie
entsprechende Kapitalkosten oder
Rohstoffkosten haben dass diese
Diskussion stattfindet aber die
Definition des übergewinns wird im
deutschen Steuerrecht unmöglich sein das
kann man in anderen Rechtsordnungen
machen die Spanier die Briten die mehr
ein kasuistisches Rechtssystem haben
können das wahrscheinlich besser als wir
aber in unserem Steuerrecht gilt gibt
ein gibt es einen Grundsatz der wie ein
Heiligtum verehrt wird das ist die
Gleichmäßigkeit der Besteuerung und das
ist Ausschluss des Artikels drei des
Grundgesetzes Gleichmäßigkeit der
Besteuerung heißt jeder Gewinn egal
warum und wo er entsteht wird gleich
besteuert das zu durchbrechen wird
steuerrechtlich verfassungsrechtlich bei
uns nicht möglich sein so und wenn wir
uns trotzdem mit dem Problem
beschäftigen müssen dann würde ich es
gerne so sehen dass wir wie es am Anfang
gesagt habe diesen Preismechanismus
entkoppeln so dass der Gaspreis nicht
haben wir den Preis treibt von allen
anderen energieerzeugungsquellen wie das
geht darüber werden wir heute Nachmittag
ausführlich diskutieren aber dann kann
man Deckeln und auch ein preisdeckel
wäre ein Instrument das in Frage käme es
ist nicht sehr marktwirtschaftlich aber
in einer solchen Situation wo der Markt
ohnehin durch die Verknappung von Gas so
komplett aus dem Tritt geraten ist kann
man meines Erachtens auch über ein
solches Instrument reden konkret Morgen
wenn wir beraten haben
und den Hinweis zu der Frage von Herrn
doll was die gasumlage anbelangt die
gasumlage ist nicht zu retten
sie ist von vorn bis hinten verkorkst
ich halte es für verantwortungslos was
davon Seiten des Wirtschaftsministers
organisiert worden ist er hätte es
natürlich wissen müssen dass dadurch
Unternehmen profitieren die Gewinne
schreiben und dass der belastete
deutsche Bürger jetzt noch bei der
Energie zur Kasse gebeten wird um
Unternehmen zu finanzieren die Gewinne
erwirtschaften das ist in der Tat
verantwortungslos so definitiv nicht
aufrecht zu erhalten und deswegen werden
wir den Antrag im Deutschen Bundestag
stellen dass die gasumlage gestoppt wird
jeglicher Versuch jetzt an dem Murks
weiter rumzumurksen davor kann man nur
warnen das muss eine andere Lösung an
dieser Stelle geben vornehmlich für ein
Unternehmen das in einer besonderen
Schieflage ist das geht auch mit
direkten Hilfen und das geht übrigens
auch mit weiteren Krediten wir werden
auch darüber reden müssen ob Unternehmen
die jetzt Unterstützung erwarten einen
Teil dieser Unterstützung später wieder
zurückzahlen auch das ist alles
richtiger und besser als eine vermurkste
Umlage weiter in irgendeiner Form zu
verändern um nur am Schluss Recht haben
zu wollen habe ich muss einsehen dass er
hier ganz großen Bockmist gebaut hat und
vielleicht darf ich das noch
abschließend hinzufügen in die
belastungskaskade oder die
haftungskaskade in solchen Fällen muss
ja auch die Fremdkapitalgeber und die
Eigenkapitalgeber mit umfassen auch die
Aktionäre des Unternehmens sind gefragt
die Kreditgeber des Unternehmens sind
gefragt und dann erst kommt der Staat
ins Spiel und dann erst kommen die
Verbraucher ins Spiel und wir haben
erprobte Mittel wir hatten mal einen
Soffin der für die Banken eingerichtet
worden ist wir haben mal
bildschirmverfahren entwickelt für die
Lufthansa also mir erschließt es sich
überhaupt nicht dass die Umlage die
Habeck da geplant hat die einzige und
die das Kabinett ja schon beschlossen
hat also nur nur damit das klar ist
worüber wir reden wir reden über eine
Rechtsverordnung der Bundesregierung die
bereits beschlossen worden ist und die
der Bundestag zurückholen könnte aber
nicht ändern kann so wir haben diesen
Antrag gestellt sie zurückzuholen es
gibt andere Möglichkeiten den gasimport
in Deutschland so zu organisieren dass
er auch bezahlbar bleibt es muss nicht
mit dieser Umlage geschehen so vielen
Dank für Ihr Interesse herzlichen Dank
wir sehen uns wieder heute morgen
genauso okay Gott ja das ist gut zu
wissen das war so live von der Zugspitze
die Pressekonferenz von Alexander
Dobrindt und Friedrich Merz noch ganz
kurz und schnell weil sie weg müssen
Herr Professor Korte März sagt auf die
Frage ob die Union bereit wäre zu
übernehmen er sagt ja wenn heute die
Regierung zusammenbrechen würde
auseinanderfallen würde würde die Union
morgen übernehmen können ist das
tatsächlich jetzt eine andere Union in
diesem Herbst 2022 als im letzten Jahr
ich sage Klammer auf mit der keiner
verhandeln wollte Klammer zu nein das
ist keine andere denn er hat auch da
verwiesen dass sie sich inhaltlich
weiter profilieren wollen und an den
großen Themen großen Debatten dieser
Republik teilnehmen wollen als Union und
das muss noch nachgeschärft werden
deswegen ist die Union ja auch dabei in
der Vorbereitung des kommenden
Parteitags in Hannover ein
Grundsatzprogramm auf den Weg zu bringen
um sich eben über die zentralen Fragen
dieser Republik neu zu orientieren das
ist im regierungsalltag verloren
gegangen für was die Union wirklich
steht insofern war das auch hier eine
Antwort darauf ansonsten haben wir die
bekannten Positionen gehört zur
Atomkraft und auch zur gasumlage und so
weiter März hat dann aber noch mal
sozusagen retrospektiv mit dem Blick auf
diesen Sommer auf das was in diesem
Sommer geschah im Bundeskanzler den
Auftritt in Sachen um die Ohren gehauen
und den Auftritt in Sachen Bast den
palästinensischen Präsidenten der ja in
Berlin zu Gast war war das jetzt
sozusagen die
Pflichtübungen von März oder trifft er
ihn damit noch mal damit trifft er das
noch mal auf den Punkt was er auch an
Kritik der Bundesregierung
entgegensteuert sehr personalisiert und
bringt es noch mal in Rückerinnerungen
weil das ja schon dabei sind wieder zu
vergessen das ist
überraschungsfrei aus Sicht der
Opposition so was zu machen aber das an
dem Beginn der Pressekonferenz zu
stellen fand ich jetzt schon interessant
noch mal in einer Schärfe die man ihm im
Bundestag oft so zutraut aber er ist bei
Pressekonferenzen oft nicht
gleichermaßen nutzt das ist typisch
Opposition auch personalisiert das
andere war auch klassisch Opposition
also auf Zeitlichkeit setzen schneller
als zu handeln auf bestimmte Leistungen
zu verweisen mehr als es zu geben und
das dritte was Opposition auch stark
gesagt ist natürlich
Alternativvorschläge und da gab es ein
paar und das macht Opposition ja auch
wichtig im Land dass man mit neuen und
anderen Argumenten etwas versucht
vorzuschlagen Professor Korte das war
sozusagen unser Reigen zu diesen
Pressekonferenzen zu den Klausurtagungen
der Fraktion im Deutschen Bundestag ich
sage vielen Dank für diese Analysen und
danke dass Sie bei uns im Studio waren
danke